monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sans contestation les deux
grands défis de notre siècle qui déjà se
déroule devant nos yeux sont les
questions
environnementales et les questions
migratoires les question environnemental
chacun le sait chacun le commente chacun
le voit les questions migratoires c'est
moins évident dans les débats
médiatiques dans les débats politiques
et à la lecture encore de la presse de
ce matin nous pourrions croire que la
France est une île même si on a vu
récemment que le fait de se refermer sur
ce île n'était pas très efficace en
matière
d'immigration 110 millions de déplacé
dans le monde c'est le nombre de
personnes que constate le HCR le Haut
Commissariat au réfugiés en 2023 du fait
des guerres du Soudan de la Syrie de
l'Afghanistan de l'Ukraine notre
continent le Europe est entourée de
terres instables le Caucase le Proche et
le Moyen-Orient le Sahel la
Libye les pays du Sud du monde
accueillent 3/4 de ses
déplacés mais l'Europe connaî elle aussi
une augmentation de son immigration
irrégulière de ses demandes d'asile plus
de 60 % depuis le début de l'année
concerne tous les pays concerne tous les
régimes politiques concerne tous les
gouvernants
à cela se rajoute 21 à 24 millions de
réfugiés par an du fait des dérèglements
climatiques 6000 par
jour les pays les plus pauvres sont 5
fois plus touchés par les dérèglements
climatiques faisant naître encore plus
de départ de leur population vers
l'Occident vers l'Europe en un mot nous
n'avons pas fini de parler d'immigration
et peut-être tant mieux car mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs parler
d'immigration c'est parler de notre
souveraineté de ce qui fait un état de
ses frontières du choix de ceux qui
veulent accueillir sur son territoire de
ceux qui veulent intégrer dans quellees
condition de ceux dont on veut se
séparer en parler est certes difficile
car il s'agit de femmes d'hommes
d'enfants mais en parler est nécessaire
et émidemment
politique parler d'immigration c'est
parler notre modèle républicain
social de sa capacité à intégrer des
moyens qu'on lui octroie des règles
fixe parler d'immigration c'est aussi
parler de sécurité et parler
d'immigration c'est enfin parlé aux
Français mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs comme moi vous rencontrez vos
électeurs comme moi vous liseer les
sondages les Français sont préoccupés
par l'immigration ils sont parfois
paradoxaux mais il nous demande toutes
et tous de légiférer et de prendre des
décisions le texte que propose le
gouvernement est une de ces propositions
le texte que propose le gouvernement ici
devant vous avec
l'humilité du ministre de l'Intérieur
qui depuis 3 ans et demi est en charge à
la demande du Président de la République
et de la première ministre de ces
questions est ouvert à la discussion
avec le Parlement avec le Sénat pour
construire ensemble un texte ferme un
texte juste et surtout un texte
efficace ce qui va compter pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur que je suis ce
ne sont pas les
postures ce n'est pas les futures
majorités c'est l'efficacité
oui ou non sommes-nous capables de doter
notre pays nos services de police nos
services de
préfecture tous ceux qui travaillent
dans le monde parfois difficilees des
questions migratoires pour plus
d'efficacité pour répondre à la la
demande d'autorité des Français pour
répondre aux exigences
d'intégration et pour éviter en effet
que les populistes ne surf son
incapacité qu'à l'état qu'on les États à
appliquer leur
décision le gouvernement est cohérent en
vous proposant la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur voilà un an
que vous avez très majoritairement voté
ici ce texte que vous avez très
largement voté y compris au-delà de la
majorité sénatoriale donner 25 % de plus
pour les crédits d'intégration du
ministère de l'Intérieur et prévoyez le
début d'une refonte extrêmement
importante des préfectures et du travail
que font les préfectures au service de
nos
concitoyens je veux ici dire monsieur le
président de la commission des lois que
ce que vous m'avez demandé voilà plus de
2 ans la refondte du travail des
préfectures de France et je veux à
travers ces propos saluer tous les
agents de préfecture tous ceux qui
tiennent les bureaux
les accueil dans des conditions parfois
très difficiles pour accueillir nos
compatriotes mais aussi ceux qui
étrangers veulent des titres de séjour
ou à qui parfois nous disons de repartir
chez eux cette réforme des préfectures
qui n'est pas législatif accompagne ce
texte de loi et la conséquence de la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur une réforme profonde
réglementaire que je m'engage à
présenter devant vous dans les
prochaines semaine pour qu'elle soit
effective au 1er janvier de l'année
prochaine et qui prévoit en quelques
mots de mettre tous les moyens pour
constater l'intégration des personnes
pour regarder les titres de séjour
lorsqu'ils sont déposés la première fois
pour lutter avec force contre tous ceux
qui ont des casiers judiciaires ou qui
font des actes de délinquence dans notre
pays et qui abusent de notre générosité
pour les renvoyer dans leur pays pour
appliquer les fameux eqtf devenu
désormais un mot synonyme d'incapacité
pour les Français à appliquer les
reconduites du territoire et en même
temps de ne pas embêter tous ces
étrangers qui qui vivent depuis tant
d'années parfois depuis des dizaines
d'années sur le sol national et qui ne
font de mal à personne et qui parfois
attendent longtemps des renouvellements
de titrre de séjour je pense à ce
Chibani de tourcoin celui qui depuis 45
ans est sur le sol national qui certes a
gardé la nationalité de son pays
d'origine mais a combattu dans les
armées françaises et dont la République
ne s'honore pas à le faire patienter
devant la préfecture du Nord pour
renouveler son titre de séjour alors
qu'à 80 ans il ne fait de mal à personne
et j'ai qui chante la Marseillaise comme
nous tous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs après la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'intérieur après la
refonte de la vie de nos préfectures est
venu aussi le temps européen de
modification de nos règles d'asile et
d'immigration l'Europe n'a pas de
gouvernance politique de l'immigration
elle a une gouvernance économique de
l'immigration
elle a des conseils des ministes de
l'économie et des finances qui se
réunissent pour la zone euro et alors
que nos frontières sont communes alors
que les enjeux sont planétaires nous
n'avons pas ou très difficilement une
seule voix pour parler d'immigration en
Europe il est évident que l'une des
grandes réponses au défi migratoires
c'est
l'Europe toutous les gouvernants et
compris ceux qui ont fait campagne
électorale contre l'Europe en sont à
appelé la Commission européenne ou le
Parlement européen ou les collègues des
autres ministères européens de
l'intérieur pour pouvoir répondre aux
crises comme c'est récemment le cas
encore à Lampedusa oui il faut des
règles européennes oui il faut une libre
circulation à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne que si et seulement si les
frontières extérieures de l'Europe sont
tenues et fermement tenues aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le
cas sous la présidence française le
président de la République a porté le
pacte asile et immigration qui depuis 20
ans traîne dans les bureau de la
Commission
européenne la France je crois par son
dynamisme mais aussi avec la alliance
politique de la plupart des pays
européens a réussi à faire adopter deux
textes essentiels pour notre Europe et
pour la
France d'abord
Eurodac jusqu'à présent tout étranger
qui arrive en Europe n'est pas
enregistré ici ou là il connaît un
accueil parfois on le pousse vers
d'autres pays et les Français constatent
comme nos policiers et nos gendarmes
courageux qu'on ne sait pas qui ils sont
qu'on ne connaitt pas leur âge sont-ils
majeurs sont-ils mineurs qu'on ne sait
pas pourquoi ils viennent chez nous et
lorsqu'on les interpelle ils demandent
l'asile les relâchant ainsi pour être
dans un nouveau processus long qui
empêche la République de savoir qui elle
peut accueillir sur le territoire
national Eurodac adopté par le Conseil
européen et j'espère bientôt voté par le
Parlement européen l'élection
européennne permettra d'enregistrer tous
les étrangers sur le sol européen de
prendre leurs empreintes de connaître le
identité de connaître leur âge de
pouvoir reconstituer leur état civil et
de permettre demain grâce à ethas et une
disposition monsieur président de la
commission des lois et dans ce texte
c'est-à-dire que toutes les polices
européennes pourront connaître ce
fichier et avoir lorsqu'ils
interpelleront quelqu'un l'identité de
cette personne sans refaire le processus
mortifère que j'évoqué tout à l'heure de
l'incapacité des États à agir alors nous
pourrons connaître tous ceux qui
arrivent sur notre sol quelles sont
leurs identités et nous lutterons ainsi
férocement contre l'immigration
irréguliè hier deuxième texte très
important porter en européen c'est
évidemment l'asile à la frontière la
fiction de non-entrée physique juridique
sur le sol européen il y a tant de gens
qui arrivent en Europe de pays où nous
partons parfois en vacances de pays où
nous avons des relations diplomatiques
extrêmement fortes de pays où il n'y a
aucune dictature aucune difficulté et
pour autant beaucoup de demandes d'asile
et qui en embolise bien sûr les services
et qui empêche parfois de rendre une
réponse rapide à ceux qui ont vraiment
besoin de l'asile en France le principe
d'asile à la frontière nous permettra
très rapidement de pouvoir distinguer
ceux qui ont des taux de protection
élevé ce qui méritent évidemment
l'oreille attentif et humaniste de
l'Europe et ceux qui abusent et qui
utilisent le droit d'asile comme un
détournement de procédure ces deux
textes s'ils sont voté très
prochainement par le Parlement européen
aideront tous les Européens et donc la
France à être plus efficace et être plus
rapide mais je l'ai dit mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est plein
d'humilité mais aussi plein de
volontarisme que le gouvernement se
présente devant la Haute chambre avec un
projet de loi qui a été déposé sur le
bureau du Sénat voilà quelques mois
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteur qui
a été adopté par la commission des Lois
du Sénat ce que je l'en remercie à
quelques détails près sur le texte du
Gouvernement et qui arrivant à 27
articles est arrivé à une cinquantaine
d'articles c'est-à-dire que la
Commission des lois du Sénat après avoir
supprimé seulement deux articles du
projet de loi on a rajouté quasiment
autant et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer publiquement et dans votre
hémicycle par ailleurs aux questions
pour dire que le gouvernement ferait
évidemment un avis favorable à la quasi
intégralité des dispositions présentées
par la majorité sénatoriale trouvant
ainsi de l'écho à la
coconstruction partant ainsi du principe
que le texte du gouvernement n'était pas
mauvais puisqu'il a été adopté par la
commission des lois du Sénat mais
partant du principe que le gouvernement
n'avait pas raison tout seul et qu'il
fallait le construire avec l'ensemble
des
parlementaires le texte de loi que j'ai
eu l'honneur de proposer au nom du
gouvernement au nom du Président de la
République et qui prend source
directement dans sa campagne
présidentielle repose sur deux mots la
fermeté et la
simplification fermeté
d'abord fermeté contre les étrangers
délinquants les Français ne comprennent
pas que nous n'arrivions pas à éloigner
ou à expulser du territoire national des
personnes qui ont commis des crimes des
crime de sang des personnes qui s'en
sont pris à leurs femmes aux policiers
qui trafiquent de la drogue et que ni la
Constitution ni la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme n'empêche
d'expulser mais que la loi française
empêche d'expulser l'année dernière
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
demandé et obtenu l'expulsion de 2500
étrangers délinquent je n'ai pas pu
obtenir et même pas pu demander à la
justice de notre pays l'expulsion de
4000 personne non pas parce que je
n'avais pas les laissé passer
consulaires des pays non pas parce qu'un
juge aurait trouvé que cette expulsion
était disproportionnée mais parce que le
législateur voilà 25 ans quasiment a
décidé qu'il ne fallait pas en plus de
la peine qu'on courait un étranger qui
commettait un acte grave qui ne fallait
pas l'éloigner ou l'expulser du
territoire national inventant ainsi les
réserves d'ordre public les personnes
qui sont arrivées avant 13 ans son l'âge
dans notre pays ou ceux qui se sont
mariés par exemple dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un qui est
arrivé à 12 ans et demi sur le sol
national qui a 19 ans commet un
crime celui-ci je ne peux pas l'expulser
mais celui qui arrive à 13 ans et demi
sur le territoire national et qu'à 19
ans pour plein de raisons commet un
délit imaginons qu'il veulent une
voiture celui je peux l'expulser qu'
a-t-il de logique Mesdames et Messieurs
les parlementaires à ce texte de loi je
viens demander au Sénat je viens
demander à l'Assemblée nationale de
lever les réserves d'or publi et de
permettre au ministrre de l'Intérieur
d'appliquer ce que demandent les
Français la fermeté que ceux que nous
accueillons généreusement sur notre
territoire respectent nos règles s'ils
ne les respectent pas s'ils sont en
responsabilité de commettre des crimes
des délits si ils ne respecte pas les
valeurs de la République alors oui
obtenons leur éloignement leur exulsion
du territoire national
fermeté également dans le retrait ou le
non renouvellement des cartes de
résidents quel que soi ces cartes de
résident quel que soit le statut quel
que soit la nationalité des personnes
qui sont étrangers en France mais qui ne
respectent pas non plus les règles
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'Intérieur
les Français doivent le savoir ne peut
pas retirer un titre de séjour en tout
cas pas dans tous les cas lorsque nous
avons connaissance des services de la
justice des services de la police des
services de la DGSI que cette personne
ne respecte pas les règles de la
République fermeté contre les
passeurs il y a un écosystème mafieux
qui utilise la misère humaine en faisant
du trafic contre beaucoup d'argent pour
faire venir en France pour faire venir
en Europe des femmes des enfants des
hommes les passeurs ne sont pas de
gentils organisateurs de leur venue en
Occident ce sont des criminels dont
l'argent finance l'argent de la drogue
l'argent du terrorisme l'argent de la
prostitution et nous devons les
combattre et aujourd'hui être un passeur
c'est en courir le risque d'un délit les
27 morts de la Manche les corps de ces
femmes enceintes repêché à 3 degrés que
les services sauvteurs des policiers des
gendarmes des bénévoles sont allés
malheureusement recourir jusque dans la
mort en novembre dernier ceux qui
étaient responsab responsable de leur
mort ce n'étaient pas les policiers
français qui tous les jours plonge dans
la mer du Nord pour essayer de récupérer
un peu de vie et donner un peu d'espoir
aux migrants qui essaient de tenter la
chance en Grande-Bretagne ce ne sont pas
nos règles qui sont responsables de cela
mais des criminels qui aujourd'hui ne
sont responsable que d'un délit devant
la justice fermeté contre les passeurs
c'est passer de délit à crime jusqu'à 20
ans de prison c'est ce qu'il y a dans ce
texte considérant que trafiquer avec le
terrorisme trafiquer avec la drogue ou
trafiquer avec les êtres humains c'est
la même chose et et mérite la sévérité
des tribunaux fermeté contre les
marchands de sommeil qui ici n'a pas été
élu local et n'a pas vu son centre-ville
son urbanisme devenu une passoire une
passoire parce que devant le travail
qu'essaient de faire les élus il y a
toutes ces règles d'urbanisme ces
difficultés où l'on voit désormais des
personnes souvent ne déclarant pas leur
recette au fisque parfois étrangers
eux-mêmes qui utilisent la misère des
gens pour pouvoir les og sans quittance
de loyer sans lavabo sans électricité
avec de la mule avec des enfants de
quelques
mois oui être marchand de sommeil c'est
comme être passeur c'est criminaliser
les êtres humains des dispositions
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois pour la première fois qui
attaque aussi durement les marchands de
sommeil sont dans ce texte de loi pour
casser en effet l'écosystème des
irréguliers et en tout cas de
l'immigration irrégulière fermeté contre
certains patrons voyou
qui embauche en le savant pertinemment
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
qu'ils exploitent dans des conditions
inacceptable inacceptable bien sûr pour
la concurrence on est toujours moins
cher lorsqueon embe les S papiers qu'on
a ni inspection du travail ni cotisation
ni charge
patronale mais évidemment inacceptable
pour ces personnes qui subissent le
jou parfois moyenâux de patrons qui font
du chantage à la régularisation de
patrons qui utilise la misère pour
éviter de donner des bonnes conditions
sociales et des droits syndicaux aux
salariés la disposition que le Sénat
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois a supprimé en son article 8 est
une excellente disposition et je veux
ici le dire sans aucune espèce d'esprit
de posture nous l'pportons avec Olivier
du soft je proposerai ce sera assez rare
dans ce débat monsieur le Président un
amendement de réétablissement
oui il faut fermer administrativement
les entreprises qui siamment embauchent
les S papiers sinon vous allez pas tarir
le flux des personnes irrégulières qui
viennent dans notre pays il est
illogique de vouloir ne pas régulariser
des personnes qui sont sans papier et ne
pas vouloir fermer les entreprises qui
les font venir mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs alors oui votons l'article 8
travaillons-le s'il est mal rédigé mais
luttons fortement contre ceux qui
embauchent les sans papiers et qui ne le
déclarent pas il y a évidemment des
personnes qui parce qu'elles utilisent
un allice ou parce qu'elle devienne
irrégulière parce que la préfecture n'a
pas répondu assez vite devienne
irrégulier le patron n'est pas voyou le
patron parfois vient voir le
parlementaire le député le sénateur le
maire et lui dit ou le préfet voilà j'ai
une situation indésirable elle vient de
tomber sur la tête de mon salarié
comment on peut s'arranger et puis il y
a d'autres patrons don vous le savez qui
malheureusement utilisent cette misère
humaine pour faire plus de profit je
crois que c'est le devoir de la droite
comme de la gauche du centre comme de
tous ceux qui sont indépendants de
lutter contre la filière d'immigration
irrégulière que représente parfois un
patronat sans scrupule et puis fermeté
dans les exigence d'intégration mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs aujourd'hui
pour avoir une carte de séjour long
contrairement à beaucoup de pays du
monde il faut prendre des cours de
français mais personne ne vérifie si ces
cours de français ont été parfaitement
effectués et surtout s'ils ont été
efficaces ce texte de loi donne une
mesure qui à mon avis est attendue par
tout le monde et d'abord je crois par
les étrangers qui veulent s'intégrer
nous mettons beaucoup plus de moyens
d'intégration je l' dit pour la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous prévoyons que pendant
par exemple le temps de travail on
puisse prévoir voilà un article que le
Sénat a aussi supprimé malheureusement
le temps pour apprendre le français
parce qu'une femme de ménage qui fait
1h30 de ROR pour travailler à 4h30 du
matin et qui repart à 1h30 de ROR à 7h
du matin et qui a deux enfants chez elle
dans une dans une ville très éloignée
par exemple du centre de Paris ce n'est
pas vrai qu'elle a le temps à 14h30
d'aller à la préfecture dans une
association prendre des cours de
français et la disposition que je vous
ai proposé c'est que pendant les heures
de travail pendant le contrat de travail
l'employeur qui a une responsabilité
sociale pas de taxe une responsabilité
sociale comme dans ma région dans le
nord de la France il y a eu le 1%
logement et je vous propose 1 %
intégration si je dire il a une
responsabilité sociale des employeurs
pendant que les employeurs embauchent
des personnes qui n'auraient pas toutes
les capacités d'intégration et par
exemple qui parleraient pas français et
notamment les femmes l'immense majorité
de l'intégration dans le travail ce sont
les femmes c'est une immigration
féminine qui essaie de travailler dans
notre pays alors oui il faut non
seulement que le patron autorise que
pendant les heures de travail on
apprenne le français mais que il y ait
un examen pour savoir si oui ou non on a
réussi cet examen de français si on l'a
réussi on a le droit d'avoir un titre de
séjour long sur le territoire national
si on a pas réussi on ne peut pas
s'intégrer on doit quitter le territoire
national c'est ce que nous proposons ici
je rappelle que c'est c'est ce que
propose la plupart des grands pays qui
nous entourent il est inimaginable de
travailler aux États-Unis sans avoir un
travail régularisé sans parler anglais
nous proposons rien d'autre que de
pouvoir intégrer les personnes au moment
le président de la République et tous
ensemble ici j'ai cru comprendre dans
les débat récemment ont défendu la
langue française je ne comprendrai pas
évidemment le gouvernement comprendrait
pas que nous trouvions pas un accord sur
le fait qu'il faut savoir parler
français pour s'intégrer en France sinon
pas de titre de séjour fermeté donc mais
aussi simplification et là monsieur le
président de la commission des lois je
dois appeler des coupables je plaide
coupable de
plagiat la
simplification les simplifications des
procédures c'est le rapport buffet
rapport buffet qui n'est pas que le
rapport buffet qui est le rapport de
tout le Sénat puisque je crois savoir
Monsieur le Président que tous les
groupes politiques alors représentés
dans l'ancienne chambre sénatoriale ont
adopté votre rapport qui lui-même
s'inspirait d'un rapport du Conseil
d'État le drame de notre politique
migratoire le drame de la non
application des eqtf nonobstant les
évocations que tout à l'heure nous
citions sur les réserves d'ordre public
c'est le fait que nous soyons longs
beaucoup trop long la loi colon a permis
la rapidité de l'OFPRA l'agence qui au
ministère de l'Intérieur regarde les
demandes d'asile avant que monsieur
colon ne présente son texte c'était à
peu près un an désormais c'est 5 mois
nous avons gagné à peu près en moyenne
bien évidemment il y a des cas
particuliers deux fois plus de temps
pour répondre OUI ou NON à quelqu'un
mais la justice administrative elle
continue à être lente notamment la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile alors
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs un
exemple imaginons quelqu'un qui vient en
France ce matin et qui traversant les
mir demande
l'asile imaginons quelqu'un qui détourne
le droit d'asile arrive ce matin et se
dit tiens pour rester en France je vais
demander
l'asile ces deux personnes vont d'abord
déposer leur dossier à l'OFPRA et en 5
mois à peu près nous allons lui répondre
oui ou non nous ne sommes pas
laxistes 70 % des cas l'OFPRA dit non
nous refusons 70 % des demandes d'asile
en France nous avons l'un des taux de
refus les plus importants
d'Europe on lui dit non qu'est-ce qu'il
fait il fait un recours il va devant la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile là c'est
entre 9 mois et un an ça fait déjà
quasiment un an et demi la Cour
nationale droit d'asile n'est pas l'xist
plus dans 70 % des cas également elle
dit
non que fait-il il attend que le préfet
lui mette un arrêté de reconduite du
territoire un eqtf et là leqtf est
susceptible de recours et donc il fait
un recours pendant ce tempslà le
ministre de l'Intérieur il peut pas
expulser cette personne donc on attend
vous savez bien que 40 à 50 % de
contentieux de vos tribunaux
administratifs c'est le droit des
étrangers 60 % cours d'appel les cours
administratifes d'appel les tribunaux
administratifs au territoire écoute de
moins en moins les doléances de vos élus
locaux sur l'urbanisme mais de plus en
plus ne font que du contentieux des
étrangers et donc cet étranger qui est
déjà arrivé voilà depuis plus d'un an et
demi sur le territoire national il va
attendre encore 9 mois que le tribunal
administratif de Lille par exemple lui
dise non parce que dans 70 % des cas il
lui dit non et qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
après ben il saisit le Conseil d'État
encore suspensif voilà comment quelqu'un
à qui on va dire non quatre fois à qui
on a mis un arrêté de reconduite à la
frontière à qui on a sans doute négocié
un laissé passer consulaire avec tel ou
tel pays peut rester 2 ans à 3 ans sur
le territoire national sans que nous
puissions l'expulser et pendant ce temps
là cette personne peut-être qu'il aura
été embauché par un patron voillou parce
qu'il faut qu'il vive il aura peut-être
eu l'occasion d'avoir effectivement
accès au logement on en reparlera il
aura peut-être eu accès à la santé on en
reparlera aussi il aura peut-être fait
des enfants sur le territoire national
et s'il a fait des enfants et siil s'est
mari alors le ministre d'intérieur ne
peut pas l'expulser puisqu'il rentrera
dans les réserves d'ord publi qui
m'empêche de l'expulser
ce que je vous demande c'est qu'on
puisse dire oui ou non à quelqu'un mais
vite pour la première fois le
gouvernement ne vient pas devant vous en
changeant les pays qui sont sûrs ou pas
sûrs ou change les critères de l'asile
il vous dit que nous avons en moyenne
des bons critères des agents courageux à
l'OFPRA des juges en général qui
écoutent la demande du ministère de
l'intérieur mais qui sont aussi
sensibles à la misère de telle ou telle
personne et que en moyenne nous disons
non à 70 % des gens qui se présentent
chez nous simplement nous leur disons
NON au bout de 3 ans et quand on leur
dit oui à la fin au bout de 3 ans est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une vie pour
la France de les faire vives de l'ADA de
l'aide sociale du Conseil d'État euh que
que qu'on qu'on nous octroie ici de
quelques centaines d'euros et de
forcement est parfois pris dans la
spirale soit du travail illégal soit
pire de la difficulté et de la
délinquence ce qu'on vous demande et ce
qui est inspiré par le rapport buffet
c'est la rapidité nous avons 12
procédures mesdames Mames et messieurs
les sénateurs dans notre droit 12
procédures pour pouvoir contester des
décisions qui concne les étrangers il
n'y a pas d'autres contentieux plus
complexe nous proposons de passer de 12
à 3 de 12 à 4 en débat avec la
commission de diviser par 3 de diviser
par 3 le nombre de contentieux possible
pour que nous puissions vite dire oui ou
dire non simplification dans recours à
la vidéo audience simplification dans la
réforme de l'asile en territorialisant
l'OFPRA pour que y compris pour la C NDA
il y ait des réponses de proximité pour
la justice administrative pour aller
plus vite simplification de travail des
policiers aujourd'hui les policiers ne
peuvent pas par coerition demander
l'empreinte des personnes c'est dans le
texte de loi simplification pour que
ceux qui sont nos frontières puissent
regarder ce qui se passe dans une
voiture aujourd'hui à la frontière entre
la France et la Belgique ou entre Menton
et l'Italie lorsqu'on voit qu'il y a des
bouées ou des moteurs de bateau dans une
voiture les policiers ne peuvent pas
arrêter cette voiture sans rquisition du
procureur de la République le texte de
loi évidemment simplifie et donne des
moyens à nos policiers simplification
bien évidemment pour tous ceux qui
abusent de notre droit au séjour et
notamment de la demande d'asile le
ministre de l'intérieur ne peut pas
retirer la carte de résident d'un
individu qui aurait imaginons le statut
de réfugié en France imaginons à Chechen
et qui repart allaéé en
Chechenie les Français doivent savoir
que le ministre d'intérieur ne peut pas
retirer la carte de résident d'un Tchen
qui a le grade si je dire de réfugié
politique et qui l'étaé repartant en
tchenéie N donc pas pour chasser dans le
pays qui normalement mérite qu'on le
protège de cette dictature évidente
évidemment je vous demande de lever tout
toutes ces imperfections et de permettre
au ministre d'intérieur de retirer ces
titres de séjour parce qu'on peut pas se
réfugier dans un politique pour lequel
on a demandé refuge dans un autre pays
ça paraît frappé du du bon sens ce n'est
pas le droit français aujourd'hui
simplification aussi dans les titre de
sé jours trop nombreux madame la
rapporteur vous le soulignez souvent
faisons un premier pas en passant la
suppression de 10 titres de séjour pour
le passeport Talan simplification
simplification
simplification ce texte est donc ferme
mais il n'est cependant pas dépourvu
d'humanité pour la première fois le
gouvernement de la République va
proposer que des enfants de moins de 16
ans ne soient plus dans les centres de
rétention administratifs il le fait déjà
depuis 1 an et à l'exception de mayottes
qui doit connaître des dispositions
particulières pour le bien du service
public et pour la raison très
particulière de nos compatriotes Maoris
le gouvernement décide que la pratique
soit dans la loi et propose au au
Parlement de
l'adopter ce texte est ferme mais il
respecte les outres maires pour la
première fois un texte réayen va
traduire en direct des dispositions qui
concernent l'article 73 ne renverra pas
à une ordonnance si je dis
les autres mèes méritent mieux qu'une
habilitation et nous serons extrêmement
ouverts aux dispositions qui n'existent
pas encore dans le texte notamment pour
la Guyane ou pour Maillotte et pour tout
évidemment territoire ultramarin qui
voudra voir son droit particulier
s'appliquer du fait de sa proximité qui
peut penser qu'on peut gérer la Guyane
et Maillotte comme on peut gérer la
corise ou le nord de la France il est
évident que le gouvernement sera très
ouvert aux dispositions proposées par
les parlementaires ultramarins et les
autres ce texte enfin est ferme mais
n'est pas FA
le gouvernement est à l'écoute de la
Haute Assemblée pour modifier ses
articles pour adopter les amendements
d'où qu'ils viennent du moment qu'il
répondent à l'efficacité à la fermeté et
à la simplicité et pour trouver le
meilleur compromis possible pour que les
Français voient que quel que soit no
différence nous avons compris qu'il nous
demandait d'agir
ensemble ce texte prévoit d'autres
amendements du Gouvernement que j'ai
partagé avec Mesdames et Messieurs le
rapporteurs et Monsieur président de la
commission des lois je proposerai
notamment une modification complète du
travail du juge des libertés et de la
détention en lien avec monsieur le garde
des saau pour que les juges et liberté
de la détention ne libèent pas les
personnes dans les centres de rétention
administratifs pour des raisons de forme
ou de nulité de la procédure mais qui
regarde la dangerosité des personnes
qu'on a voulu mettre en rétention afin
de les expulser aujourd'hui ceux qui
sont en centre de rétention
administratif mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et je vous rappelle que vous
avez voté une loi qui prévoyait passage
de 1300 à 3000 places de centre de R
administratif sont des gens qui sont
soit affichés pour radicalisation soit
connus pour des actes de délinquence
nous avons changé le public des
personnes qui sont en centre de
rétention administratif et nous nous
concentrons dans l'expulsion d'abord des
personnes dangereuses pour le bien
public je pense que c'est de bon sens le
juge des libertés de rétention ne peut
plus agir avec ce public comme il
agissait Jadice avec quelqu'un que l'on
mettait dans un centre de rétention et
qui comm commettait aucun acte délictuel
comme le public est désormais dangereux
dans les cras je souhaite nous
souhaitons je l'espère que le juge et
liberté de détention prennent en compte
la dangerosité et ne n'annule pas le
travail que fait le ministère de
l'Intérieur pour des raisons de tampon
qui manque ou pour une unité de
procédure
bénine le gouvernement proposera
également une interdiction de retour du
territoire national de 5 à 10 ans quand
les gens sont expulsés aujourd'hui nous
prenons une interdiction de retour de 5
ans dans plusieurs cas que je ne peux
expliciter ici ce serait trop long mais
je pourrais détailler devant les
parlementaires nous pensons que 10 ans
qui correspond à la fois aux règles
européennes de nos voisins et à
l'efficacité pour la sécurité publique
de nos concitoyens est une meilleure
règle que celle de 5 ans le gouvernement
va proposer un amendement qui évitera
les abus de demande d'asile quand un
policier interpelle quelqu'un qui est
irrégulier et que ce personne dit moi je
suis en demande d'asile et qui n'a pas
fait sa demande d'asile précédemment
alors aujourd'hui il relâche cette
personne et il attend que la personne
fasse d'asile demande l'asile et on a
les 3 ans de procédure qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure la disposition que très
ferme est est très forte que propose le
gouvernement c'est lorsqu'un policier
constatera quelqu'un est irrégulier et
que cette personne n'a pas déjà demandé
l'asile et qu'il se sert de l'asile pour
rester plus longtemps sur le territoire
que cette demande d'asile se fasse en
rétention et de manière
accélérée le gouvernement va également
et je pense que c'est important vu le
drame de hy dont je rappelle que le
texte était antérieur bien évidemment va
proposer une disposition pour rendre
irreceva les demandes d'asile de ceux
qui ont déjà l'asile dans un autre pays
ce qui était le cas évidemment de celui
qui a attenté à la vie de ces bébés à le
gouvernement donc proposera des
modifications encore à ce texte et enfin
je veux le dire le gouvernement n'épuise
pas les autres débats qui pourrai avoir
lieu dans ce texte des débats qui peut
être de nature bien sûr
constitutionnelle proposition de loi est
bientôt déposée des débats qui peuvent
être de nature référendire le président
de la République s'est exprimé pour
inviter les partis à discuter de
l'ouverture sur l'article 11 du
référendum y compris sur l'immigration
des débats qui peuvent être européens ou
conventionnels personne n'a jamais dit
que ce texte de loi était la réponse
absolument à tout mais personne ne peut
dire sérieusement que ce texte de loi
n'est pas ferme n'est pas celui qui
donnera à nos policiers et à nos
gendarmes des moyens supplémentaires et
personne ne peut dire que le
gouvernement n'est pas ouvert à la
discussion avec le Parlement je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
ministre je vais donner la parole à
Madame Murielle Jourda rapporteur de la
commission des
lois
vous avez la parole le rapporteur merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues je ne dispose pas comme
monsieur le ministre d'un temps bien
considérable aussi vaisje vous tracer à
grand trait le travail que nous avons pu
faire à la commission des lois pour
examiner le dernier avatar d'une litanie
de texte sur l'immigration dont le
nombre même nous laisse penser qu'ils
n'ont jamais atteint le but qui leur
était
assigné ce texte pour l'aborder nous
avons d'abord dû prendre en compte le
fait qu'il ne s'agit que la loi
ordinaire et que les contraintes qui
nous sont imposées par la Constitution
par les engagements européens
internationaux de la France nous ne
pouvions nous en affranchir dans ce
texte nous avons aussi essayé d'écarter
des quelques ponciifs qui peuvent
circuler dans la vie politique française
et qui à mon sens nuise à la bonne
efficacité des décisions que nous
pouvons prendre
non l'immigration n'est pas
systématiquement synonyme de délinquence
et ça se réfèire in jure à nos
concitoyens qui sont d'origine étrangère
que de le dire en revanche il ne
faudrait pas tomber de l'excès dans
l'aveuglement et ne pas voir qu'un
certain type de délinquence et je pense
notamment au terrorisme islamiste qui
SVIT sur notre territoire ne serait pas
en lien avec l'immigration car il est de
la même façon et dans un autre ordre
d'idée voir inversé je suis je suis
désolé monsieur le ministre c'est vous
qui prononcez le plus souvent cette
parole mais on ne peut pas toujours dire
que l'immigration soit une chance pour
la France évidemment on peut penser et
on peut voir que les étrangers
peuvent peuvent sans doute utiliser leur
force à occuper un certain nombre de
métiers en France mais c'est plus me
semble-t-il une question d'organisation
du travail qui est propre à notre marché
du travail qu'autre chose on peut aussi
se dire que effectivement côtoyer une
culture étrangère est assez
enrichissante et cela est exa si ce
n'est que aujourd'hui et bien parfois
quand cette culture prend une place qui
permettre à nos concitoyens de ressentir
ce que Laurent Bouvet avait théorisé
sous le terme d'insécurité culturelle
c'est-à-dire la sensation que
effectivement l'insécurité culturelle
caractérisée par le fait que notre
propre culture est contrecarrée sur
notre propre territoire et bien ces
citoyens n'estime pas que ce soit une
chance pour la France et puis je vais
vous le dire comme je le pense je pense
que même les immigrés estiment qu'ils ne
viennent pas en étant une chance pour la
France lorsqu'on quitte sa TER natal
lorsqu'on quitte ses proches lorsqu'on
quitte tout ce qui nous est familier
notre histoire notre tradition nos
cultures et bien il ne faut jamais
sous-estimer le déchirement qui est ce
départ l'immigration c'est quelque chose
mais l'immigration est toujours une
souffrance pour celui qui part et
lorsqu'en plus il donne les économies
familiales à ces nouveaux esclavagistes
que sont les passeurs pour risquer sa
vie en Méditerranée l'immigré ne vient
pas parce qu'il pense nous rendre
service il vient parce qu'il pense que
la chance c'est la France et que la
France est une chance pour lui alors
tous ces pensciifs ne sont pas si
simples toute cette situation n'est pas
si simple et effectivement c'est en
l'écartant que nous
avons aborder ce texte en définissant
aussi c'était également un préalable ce
que qu'une politique migratoire une
politique migr dans un pays des
frontières c'est une politique qui
consiste à dire qui a le droit d'entrer
qui a le droit de rester et à quelles
conditions dans un pays qui n'est pas le
sien et c'est ainsi que nous avons pu
constater que s'il existe 187 titres de
séjours différents en France et que
chacun sait comment y rentrer il existe
un manque terrible qui est de dire qui
et pourquoi les étrangers peuvent venir
en France et c'est pourquoi l'apport
principale de la commission des lois a
été d'introduire un titre un premier
titre qui vise à véritablement maîtriser
l'entrée sur le territoire car lorsqu'on
travaille sur ces sujets ça a été notre
cas avec Monsieur bonne carè pendant 4
ans sur le budget ça a été le cas du
président buffet depuis de nombreuses
années ce que l'on peut constater c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le nombre d'entrées
sur le territoire qui nuit à la
véritable politique migratoire car nous
ne savons pas accueillir nous ne savons
plus intégrer et tout qu'on fait nous
n'appliquons même plus les textes que
nous votons car lorsqu'on rentre en
France y compris lorsqu'on perd son
titre de séjour aprèsêtre rentré
légalement et bien nous n'avons pas la
capacité aujourd'hui en France
d'éloigner les personnes qui sont en
situation clandestine c'est-à-dire
celles qui ne respecte pas la loi
française donc ce premier titre a
consisté à tout d'abord organiser un
débat au Parlement avec la fixation de
quota autant que faire ce peut nous
dirons qui va rentrer sur le territoire
et dans quelle quantité et nous avons
également ajouté dans ce premier titre
un certain nombre de conditions pour
resserrer le regroupement familial le
titre étranger malade le étudiant
également qui se doit d'être
effectivement contrôlé plus qu'il ne
l'est aujourd'hui voilà quel est
l'apport principale de la Commission et
sur les autres sujets nous en débattrons
pendant cette séance merci merci madame
le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Philippe boncarer rapporteur de
la commission des lois vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mais chers collègues après
avoir rappelé les propos du président
Larcher sur l'immigration la situation
n'est plus tenable vous avoir dit que le
travail technique entre les rapporteurs
s'était très bien déroulé que la
majorité sénatoriale est d'accord sur la
quasi totalité des sujets et vous avoir
dit qu'il existe et vous avoir dit qu'il
existe des solutions pour réécrire
l'article 3 je voudrais organiser mon
propos introductif sur quatre points
premièrement nous avons une obligation
de résultat deuxièmement l'engagement de
fermeté respecté troisièmement nous vous
proposons un retour du Parlement dans la
définition de la politique migratoire et
qurièmement nous nous inscrivons dans le
cadre conventionnel et constitutionnel
le tout au service de l'action publique
premièrement une obligation de résultat
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là et
bien le Sénat doit adopter un texte
personne ne comprendrait qu'il ne soit
pas en mesure de répondre à l'attente de
nos concitoyens et vous savez aussi que
le refus du temps dit programmé à
l'Assemblée nationale peut laisser
planer un doute sur la capacité de
celle-ci d'aller au bout des débats et
donc personne ne comprendrait que les
deux assemblées ne soient pas en mesure
d'élaborer un texte c'est une question
de légitimité parlementaire et tout
particulièrement pour le Sénat vous le
savez tous nous estimons que le Sénat
est aujourd'hui le point d'équilibre
institutionnel il nous appartient d'être
cohérent avec nous-mêmes et de le mettre
en œuvre dans ce texte vous dire
également que deuxièmement ce texte
introduit des éléments Indis discutable
de de fermeté vous en aurez de nombreux
témoignages c'était déjà l'objet du
texte présenté par Monsieur le Ministre
de l'Intérieur qui vient de s'enexliquer
vous avez eu une première étape avec la
commission des lois du mois de mars et à
l'occasion de la séance une deuxième
étape nous permettra d'adopter de
nouveaux amendements c'est bien un
nouveau paysage de la politique
migratoire du pays qui se dessine et une
addition de mesures vous dire aussi
troisièmement que il y a me semble-t-il
dans ce texte en tout cas dans
l'évolution que nous avons voulu lui
donner un retour du Parlement à quoi je
fais référence je fais référence au fait
que la politique migratoire n'est pas
simplement une politique diplomatique
pas plus qu'une politique mémorielle
elle est régalienne elle s'écrit au
présent et elle s'écrit au présent sous
le contrôle du Parlement dans le débat
annuel que nous vous proposons l'article
1a du texte à travers les nombreuses
données attendu bien nous souhaitons
vous donner nous donner collectivement
les moyens d'être beaucoup plus précis
sur les évaluations de notre politique
migratoire et surtout d'en fixer les
objectifs c'est bien ça l'idée de
l'article 1a c'est que le Parlement
puisse redonner un cap sur la définition
de la poli tique migratoire et 4ème et
dernier élément vous dire que nous avons
essayé d'inscrire notre action en tout
cas l'analyse que vos rapporteur ont
fait des amendements dans le respect de
nos engagements conventionnels et de
notre Constitution alors j'entends très
bien le débat dans la société entre
liberté individuelle et droits collectif
mais je ne crois pas je ne crois pas que
l'État de droit entrave l'action
publique la CE admis une marge
d'appréciation nationale et si l'on veut
bien regarder avec précision les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
celui-ci n'a jamais interdit au pouvoir
exécutif ou à l'exécutif
ou au législatif de mettre en œuvre ces
politiques avec ces différents éléments
je voulais finalement peut-être
anticiper sur la suite du débat et vous
dire qu'il faudrait faire attention à ne
pas introduire des données inc
institutionnel qui n'apporte rien à la
crédibilité du Parlement et surtout qui
se retend ensuite à une censure
laisserait entendre à nos concitoyens
qu'en fait l'action publique ne serait
pas possible et c'est par cela que je
terminerai en vous disant que je crois
très profondément que la politique
migratoire qui vous est proposée
peut-être efficace elle ne sera jamais
efficace à 100 % et je partage le
sentiment d'humilité qui vous até
exprimé en préambule par le ministre de
l'intérieur mais c'est indiscutable
avec ce texte une politique qui sera
plus efficace et aussi avec les
amendements que vous apporterez merci à
tous et à toutes de votre
[Applaudissements]
attention nous
allons maintenant passer à la discussion
d'une motion tendante à opposer
l'exception des recevabilité madame
Cécile les membres du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen etcologiste aki ont
déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro 1 tendant à opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilité au texte en discussion
je donne la parole maintenant à madame
la Présidente Cécile
can pour la
motion vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues loin de nous l'idée en
déposant cette motion de laisser
sous-entendre qu'il n'y aurait pas lieu
de débattre de l'immigration dans notre
pays mais nous demeurons convaincus que
ce n'est pas avec ce texte que nous
répondrons à deux des nombreux défis de
demain l'explosion des migrations de par
le monde la lutte contre le terrorisme
et plus particulièrement actuellement le
terrorisme islamique radical nous nous
devons donc un discours de vérité sans
excès mais empli de sincérité et de
conviction sur ce sujet monsieur le
ministre c'est dans cet état d'esprit
que s'inscrit mon groupe à l'hône de
l'examen des articles de votre projet de
loi un discours de vérité car il ne
faudrait pas laisser à penser que
gestion des politiques migratoires et
lutte contre le terrorisme vont
forcément de paire il n'y a d'ailleurs
et malheureusement qu'à se retourner sur
la dernière décennie et les attentats
dont notre pays a été victime pour
constater de suite qu'immigration ne
rime pas avec terrorisme ne laissons
donc pas croire ici aux Français que ce
texte est un texte pour leur sécurité ne
laissons pas croire non plus que la
France pourrait stopper les migrations
de milliers de populations qui fuit le
dérèglement climatique les guerres la
famine le drame les drames récents et
notamment celui de Lampedusa le
démontrre oui massivement ces femmes et
ces hommes qui traversent le monde au
péril de leur vie le font car c'est pour
eux la seule chance de survie une partie
de notre planète subit actuellement
famine et ségeresse quasi permanente
cette réalité ce sont les pays les plus
riches de notre planète qui en sont
souvent les premiers responsables
déforestation massive
hyperurbanisation exploitation et
assèchement des cours d'eau exploitation
des océans et des fonds marins à ces
migrations se rajoutent les nombreux
conflits qui parfois bien loin des
plateau de télévision font des milliers
de morts des milliers de prisonniers des
milliers de filles privées d'école des
milliers d'enfants soldats des milliers
de femmes violées la réalité de la
guerre et des dictatures c'est celle-ci
et là encore c'est au péril de leur vie
à pied derrière des camions ou dans des
bateaux de fortune que chaque jour des
milliers de personnes tentent de fuir
vers un eldorado que notre pays parmi
d'autres incarne et pourtant à leur
arrivée l'Eldorado s'effondre ils ont
cherché à partir pour vivre il reste ici
pour survivre notre devoir au pays de
Voltaire et d'Hugo et de les accueillir
avec humanité oui nous avons un
impératif les sortir des mains de tous
les passeurs trafiquants et exploiteurs
en tout genre or votre texte n'y répond
pas au contraire il tente à stigmatiser
un peu plus encore ces femmes et ces
hommes qui n'ont plus rien en les
rangeant dans le camp de ceux qui
nuiraient à notre pays mais de quelle
nuisance parlons-nous pour celles et
ceux qui ne l'aurit vu je vous invite à
revoir ce magnifique documentaire
diffusé sur France Télévision nous les
ouvriers je vous invite à relire notre
histoire de France pour mesurer au
combien bien loin d'être des nuisances
ces femmes et ces hommes ont aidé la
France à se construire à se défendre à
se reconstruire P Mel ils étaient
marocains tunisiens algériens sénégalais
Ivoiriens polonais italiens espagnol
portugais et de tant d'autres pays
encore ils ont tous connu à leur arrivée
l'hostilité plus ou moins mondaine
parfois d'ailleurs d'un racisme
ordinaire mais par le travail par
l'exigence de notre République à faire
du commun et non du communautarisme ils
se sont intégrés et ont su vivre
ensemble en France je ne fais preuve
d'aucun angélisme ici car oui le monde a
changé et oui notre République ses
valeurs ont faibli la République dans la
la Constitution est définie comme
indivisible laïque démocratique et
social à nos yeux c'est en confortant
ces quatre principes que nous s que nous
sortirons du débat noséabond auquel nous
assistons depuis plusieurs années dans
notre pays un débat qui a fait renoncer
les gouvernements successifs convaincu
que la répression et la négation même de
la réalité réglerait le problème mais il
n'en est toujours rien au contraire à
nié cette réalité nous avons affaibli
notre République en renvoyant dans le
communautarisme ces personnes-là en les
excluant de nous-mêmes de notre commun
en les déshumanisant même parfois en
renforçant ainsi l'emprise des marchands
de sommeil des patrons voyou et autres
exploiteurs de la misère humaine et le
débat que nous aurons ici même sur
l'aide médicale d'État en est un exemple
frappant privé de soins préventifs des
femes fmes et des hommes au détriment de
toute politique de senti publique c'est
une catastrophe pour ces individus comme
pour notre société enfin ne soyons pas
hypocrite nous sommes nombreux dans nos
départements à avoir des parcours de
réussite et pas seulement dans les
métiers en tension nous sommes
d'ailleurs nombreux à solliciter les
préfets ici ou là pour de nombreuses
dérogations aux droits existants parfois
même monsieur le ministre à vous
interpeller directement alors si le
monde a changé nous devons donc
renforcer nos politiques nous devons
renforcer le droit au travail pour ces
femmes et ces hommes qui d'ailleurs ne
demandent que ça nous devons renforcer
la prise en charge de l'apprentissage du
français pour décommunotariser ces
personnes et les rendre libres de leur
destinée enfin nous devons créer les
structures d'accueil dignes du pays des
droits de l'homme à l'inverse de se
satisfaire des dormeurs de rue ceci doit
se traduire dans la loi et non en
renforçant le pouvoir discrétionnaire
des préfets un autre sujet je l'évoqué
est celui de la lutte contre le
radicalisme sachez monsieur le ministre
que nous serons toujours de ce combat-là
nous le savons et à titre d'exemple
l'histoire algérienne des années 90 le
démontre le radicalisme islamiste n'aime
pas les progressistes car à la doctrine
de Dieu nous répondons par la doctrine
de la République à la doctrine de
l'immobilisme facilitatrice de
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
nous répondons par la doctrine de
l'éducation et de la construction d'un
esprit critique seul facteur
d'émancipation pour les femmes et les
hommes nous ne voulons pas une
république uniformée mais une république
qui rassemble qui conjugue les talent de
chacun au service de tous Quelques
remarques de forme pour finir dans la
lignée des précédents texes ce projet de
loi participe de fait à l'inflation
normative une loi sur l'immigration tous
les 18 moi ce qui est sans équivalent et
au non respect des principes de sécurité
juridique et d'intelligibilité de la loi
alors que nous ne dispose pas d'un
appareil statistique complet ni de bilan
de la loi du 10 septembre 2018 qui
s'assignait les mêmes objectif selon
l'avis du Conseil d'État ce n'est pas
respectueux du travail de la
représentation nationale ce texte nous
le pensons en cours fortement la censure
du Conseil constitutionnel il porte plus
que jamais atteinte au droit de mener
une vie familiale normal protégé par les
juristes européennes tiré de l'article 8
de la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme et constitutionnel le Conseil
le Lian au droit au respect de la vie
privée fondé sur l'article 2 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen enfin il est examiné dans un
contexte particulier je l'évoquais de
stigmatisation des étrangers et d'un
concours l'pine des propositions les
plus dur pouvant aller jusqu'à une
remise en cause de l'état de droit qui
n'est pourtant pas toujours assumé y
compris lorsqu'il est question pour
certains acteurs politiques de bousculer
une constitution à l'égard de laquelle
ils sont d'ordinaire beaucoup plus
prudent c'est un texte rempli de
contradiction comment peut-on en même
temps poursuivre un objectif
d'intégration des des étrangers et s'en
prendre au regroupement familial comment
peut-on en même temps vouloir accélérer
les procédures d'expulsion et augmenter
les délais de rétention comment peut-on
en même temps durcir les sanctions
contre les marchands de sommeil et ne
pas accompagner davantage les victimes
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris nous ne partageons
ni le texte du Gouvernement ni celui
réécrit ici par la droite sénatoriale
cependant nous aurons jusqu'au bout le
débat avec vous car nous demeurons
convaincus que c'est dans le débat dans
la confrontation et dans la
contradiction que nous avancerons t le
sens de cette question préalable et
parce que et je le sais et sans surprise
elle sera jeté je veux vous dire ici à
chacune et chacun que nous ne lâcherons
en rien sur notre capacité à article par
article vous faire la démonstration que
d'autres solutions sont possibles sans
être néfastes à notre République et en
la faisant grandir sur la route de
l'humanité je vous remercie merci madame
la
Présidente y a-t-il de rateur contre la
motion
d'exception
d'irrecevabilité il n en a pas quel est
l' viis de la commission
oui monsieur le Président l'avis de la
commission et vous vous en doutez des
favorable pour quelques raisons que je
vais évoquer rapidement la première en
disant madame la Présidente Kirman que
l'aspiration qui la sienne à ce que le
débat soit poursuivi et amplifié suppose
déjà que le texte puisse se poursuivre
deuxièmement lui dire que elle appelle à
un discours de vérité euh c'est bien
quand même le point de départ avec un
flux d'immigration irrégulière important
entre 600 et 900000 personnes présentes
sur notre sol un dispositif
d'intégration qui est en panne et une
difficulté pour pas dire une incapacité
chronique à atteindre nos objectifs
quant au nombre de demandes d'asile nous
serons peut-être aux environ de 150000
cette année qui est sera le nombre le
plus important même si la France est
loin d'être le pays le plus attractif si
vous me permettez cette formule quand au
nombre je terminerai mon propos en
reprenant deux éléments vous avez fait
référence madame le présidente au fait
qu'il y avait des conflits multiples
vous avez bien sûr raison ce qui est une
manière de dire que le texte comme
quelquefois je l'entends dire n'est pas
une réponse à une sorte d'air du temps
un air de stimatisation mais correspond
bien à une situation géopolitique
avec un fort niveau de d'instabilité
vous avez également madame présidente
parmi vos les nombreux points que vous
avez abordé appeler à faire du commun
comment faire du commun dans la France
2023 c'est effectivement un objectif que
l'on peut volontiers partager tout en
émettant un avis défavorable sur la
motion que vous venez de nous présente
monsieur ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement merci Monsieur le
présidentid un avis défavorable mais
peut-être dire à madame la Présidente
d'abord que je partage avec elle l'envie
que ce débat se déroule se l'ai déjà dit
dans des conditions évidemment
respectueuses du débat républicain parce
que quand on parle d'immigration il me
semble l'avoir dit à la tribune on parle
effectivement de femmes et d'homm
d'enfants mais on parle aussi de femmes
et d'hommes qui au nom de la République
agissent écoutent ou parfois
accompagnent c'est le cas des
associations donc évidemment toujours un
débat respectueux puisquon ne parle pas
de matière on ne parle pas d'argent sans
doute les deux respectables mais enfin
ce qui est important effectivement c'est
c'est l'humain et la seule querelle qui
vaille c'est c'est l'homme si ce n'est
l'humain d'abord voilà donc je voulais
je voulais évidemment vous dire madame
la Présidente que c'est dans cet esprit
que que travaille le le gouvernement
peut-être deux points très rapides
madame la Présidente cependant dans
votre intervention je voudrais
m'inscrire en faux le premier c'est de
dire je l'entends souvent cet argument
et partout c'est de dire ah il y a eu 20
lois en 30 ans une tous les 18 mois bon
d'abord c'est c'est tout à fait faux
depuis que le Président de la répuique
est en responsabilité il y a eu une
seule loi en 2018 donc c'est la deuxème
loi en 6 ans sur l'immigration alors
voilà Monsieur retot dit il en faudrait
d'autres bon très bien donc il faudrait
que vous mettiez d'accord mais mais on
peut pas dire que le gouvernement fut
pris à pic sur les questions de loi
migratoirees ces dernières années une
tous les 6 ans ça me paraît raisonnable
deuxièmement vous avez voter combien de
textes budgétaires cette année combien
de textes sur l'écologie combien de
textes sur l'économie et
devant trop pas assez voyez on voit bien
la majorité sénatoriale dans sa
diversité pourquoi les questions
migratoires qui répondent qui répondent
et vous l'avez dit vous-même madame la
Présidente à une actualité
internationale forcément évidemment que
ce qui se passe dans certains pays
lorsque les talibans prennent en
responsabilité l'Afghanistan lorsqu le
bagladesh qui subit qui subit qui subit
des désirs qui subit des désirs de
changement
climatique lorsqu'il y a des difficultés
extrêmement fortes lorsque l'armée
française se retire du sel lorsqu'il y a
des coups d'État bien sûr que ça a des
conséquences sur notre pays et c'est
quand même étonnant d'avoir ce genre
d'argument l'immigration sans doute la
matière qui évolue le plus non pas selon
nos propres désirs nationaux mais selon
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur de notre
pays et considérer qu'il fait pas qu'on
s'adapte ça me paraît un drôle de
raisonnement au contraire ça me paraît
difficile de ne pas adapter nos règles
de droit au moment même au momentê quand
même on a des changements vous savez
j'entends beaucoup de comparaisons j'ai
entendu d'ailleurs des comparaisons pour
dire ah bah il y a 20 ans il y a 25 ans
oui c'est vrai c'est Monsieur Sarkozi
qui avait fait la double peine vous le
reprochez aujourd'hui ou alors à
l'époque lesqtf mais il y a 25 ans le
monde était totalement différent le
ministintérieur qui était à ma place il
avait une discussion politique et
diplomatique avec la Libye avec
l'Afghanistan avec la Syrie avec le Mali
avec le Niger avec
l'Irak quel désordre mondial désormais
comparer ce qui est incomparable me
paraît pas très honnête
intellectuellement donc il est normal
que d'utiliser la loi de la République
et peut-être d'autres instruments selon
les avancées des uns et des autres pour
modifier nos textes et notre texte
législatif et nos textes réglementaires
pour s'adapter au désordres du monde
l'immigration c'est s'adapter
malheureusement ou heureusement au
désordres du monde donc l'argument de
yois tous les 18 mois d'abord elle est
fausse le président de la République
elle vaut pour d'autres gouvernements
elle vaut pour le gouvernement
socialiste dit ce va pour le
gouvernement de droite bah oui vous en
avez fait plusieurs he des lois
migration donc c'est pas très grave et
tant mieux c'estes personnes c'est pas
moi qui vous le reprocherai et cependant
depuis 6 ans nous avons eu nous un seul
texte à vous proposer le deuxième point
c'est sur la CEDH la vie privée et
familiale est garantie mais la vie
privée et familiale est pas absolue la
vie privée et familiale n'est pas
absolue madame la Présidente le
législateur depuis très longtemps y
compris sous un gouvernement de gauche
les intérêts fond de la nation contre le
terrorisme qui on été pris par le
ministre casenu par un gouvernement
totalement je crois de gauche il y avait
pas de doute possible soutenu d'ailleurs
je me semble-t-il par une gauche très
plurielle bah le gouvernement de
Monsieur Hollande a considéré que vie
privée familiale d'accord mais pas pour
les terroristes bah nous dis on dit vie
les criminels bah ça me paraît assez
normal j'ai eu le cas madame la
Présidente à connaître de quelqu'un qui
était connu pour pédophilie condamné
comme tel condamné comme tel oui mais il
y a pas criminalité dans le texte
aujourd'hui non mais de de CRIM
pédophile de CRIM pédophile pardon si je
me suis exprimer madame la ministre
condamné comme tel dont on m'a dit qu'on
ne pouvait pas demander l'expulsion au
nom de la vie privée et familiale parce
qu'il avait des enfants vousz l'
absurdité l'absurdité dans laquelle
parfois le droit est plongé du fait que
la loi aujourd'hui est surannée dépassée
ne correspond plus au difficulté
auxquell nous faisons face et auquell le
peuple français demande que nous
légiférions donc la vie est privée et
familiale oui mais pas n'importe quel
prix a un équilibre à avoir entre les
besoins de la nation les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation ça c
terrorisme mais l'ordre public qu' soit
grave ou simple on verra sur les
articles 9 10 13 et moi je suis
favorable effectivement que nous ne
censurions pas et que nous puissions
dire nous demandons l'expulsion des
personnes même s'ils ont une vie privée
et familiale en France à partir du
moment où ils ne respectent pas l'ordre
public à partir du moment où il respecte
pas les intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation nous avons le droit nous de nous
en séparer et la CEDH ne dit pas le
contraire je con constate que dans
laaffire I cuissen alors même que le
texte n'avait pas changé et que le
Conseil d'État s'est inspiré du la loi
séparatisme que vous avez voté ici nous
avons obtenu l'expulsion de
monsieurissen contre la vie du tribunal
administratif de Paris alors que son
avocat demandait la vie privée et
familiale alors que ces quatre enfants
étaient nés en France et majeur en
France qu'il était lui-même propriétaire
en France depuis plus de 40 ans qui
s'était marié en France et que nous
avions réussi à démontrer qu'il luttait
avec séparatisme contre la République
nous avons obtenu son expulsion le juge
et notamment le juge européen notamment
le juge DH parce que c'est possible pour
la c'est possible pour le séparatisme et
pas pour les crimes et délits madame
gonri on aura l'occasion d'en parler si
vous nêtes pas toujours convaincu ce qui
est possible pour les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation et le
séparatisme bien possible pour les CRIM
et délit c'est toute la démonstration de
ce texte et je je crois qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler enfin
l'exception d' respabilité monsieur le
Président c'est je crois pour dire que
ce texte ne respecte pas les règles de
droit de notre Constitution le Conseil
d'État a donné un avis très favorable à
ce texte dans les dispositions
présentées par le gouvernement c'est une
très bonne chose et assez rare pour être
souligné laisser le conse constitionnel
faire son office je suis sûr qu'il sera
saisi il y a-t-il des demandes
d'exlication de vote je rappelle qu'ils
sont limités à un par groupe en a
pas je vais consulter le Sénat sur
l'exception
d'recevabilité je rappelle que
l'adoption de cette motion entraînerait
le rejet du texte en discussion qui est
pour cette exception
d'irrecevabilité manifeste en levant la
main avis
contraire n'est pas
adopté nous allons passer à la
discussion de la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable
elle a été déposé par Monsieur Thomas
deess les membres du groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire je vous donne la parole pour
la motion mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre Mame ministre mes chers
collègues 4 ans après l'entrée en
vigueur de la dernière loi asile
immigration monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous vous présentez devant
nous avec un nouveau texte de nouveau
pour contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration
dites-vous l'immigration et vous l'avez
dit ce sont avant tout des immigrés des
hommes et des femmes des enfants des
ados avec leur situation particulière
leurs parcours leurs aspirations leurs
difficultés et des difficultés il y en a
de loi en loi le parcours administratif
d'une personne étrangère en France est
devenu de plus en plus
indigne la conception dissuasive des
politiques françaises d'immigration est
devenue un facteur de désordre permanent
la situation de nombreux étrangers en
France parfois de mineur est marqué par
l'extrême précarité et une succession
perpétuelle d'obstacles de l'accès aux
préfectur et à l'OFI pour l'obtention ou
le simple renouvellement d'un titre de
séjour en passant par l'accès au travail
jusqu'à une prise en charge médicale
effective tout est fait texte après
texte pour rendre le parcours chaotique
un rapport de l'Assemblée nationale sur
les moyens des préfectures pour
l'instruction des demandes de séjour de
2021 décrit une situation qui a encore
empiré depuis lors du jour au lendemain
faute de rendez-vous des personnes en
situation parfaitement régulière inséré
professionnellement et socialement
basculent en situation irrégulière entre
deux titres et perdent leurs droit entre
2019 et 2022 les réclamations relatives
au droits des étrangers on augmenté de
233 et le droit des étrangers est devenu
le premier motif de saisine du Défenseur
des droits passant de 10 % des
réclamations reçues par l'institution à
24 %. cet accroissement concerne
essentiellement l'obtention de
rendez-vous les difficultés en lien avec
la dématérialisation des guichets et les
délais d'instruction excessifs cette
mise en désordre de l'immigration et ce
renoncement à nos valeurs se manifeste
aussi et en premier lieu à nos
frontières le rétablissement des
frontières depuis 2015 sans cesse
renouvelé entre la France et l'Italie
est le symbole de l'absurdité de cette
politique une une frontière de plus en
plus militarisée avec des effectifs de
plus en plus nombreux mais qui n'ont
pour seul effet que de rendre plus
dangereuse la traversée des montagnes et
qui malgré la solidarité des montagnards
provoque régulièrement des drames il y a
2 semaines un mort un homme est mort
dans la Durance la rivière qui coule
près de brillçon alors qu'il tentaient
d'échapper à un contrôle cela n'est pas
acceptable alors disons-le un contrôle
frontière entre la France et l'Italie
oui c'est l'idéal européen qui meurt à
petit feu à chaque fois qu'on renouvelle
le le rétablissement de cette frontière
entre nos pays face à cela monsieur le
ministre vous nous proposez donc de
contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration contrôler avec un mot
d'ordre clair que vous répétez à l'envie
dans les médias et encore ici fermeté
fermeté fermeté pourquoi les motivations
réelles de ce texte restent flou le
Conseil d'État comme le Défenseur des
droits ont manifesté clairement leur
regret face à l'absence d'une d'une
motivation sérieuse à ce texte je cite
l'exposé des motifs et l'étude d'impact
ne permett pas d'apprécier la mesure des
phénomènes que le projet de loi devrait
réguler ou l'inefficacité des
dispositions législatives actuelles pour
rendre les objectifs visés nous dit
ainsi le Défenseur des droits du fait de
la faiblesse de cet exposé des motifs et
de l'étude d'impact le même Défenseur
des droits s'inquiétait déjà en février
dans son avis que le débat public risque
d'être soutendu par des représentations
erroné voire discriminatoire de
l'immigration on peut dire qu'elle ne
s'était pas trompé dans votre texte ces
représentations erronées se manifeste
clairement par le renforcement de
l'arbitraire administratif pour vous
comme pour vos prédécesseurs le sérieux
d'une politique migratoire réside
uniquement dans la notre capacité à
expulser donc vous présupposez qu'en
multiplication qu'en multipliant la
distribution des obligations de quitter
le territoire français en ajoutant
contraintes et arbitraire administratif
sur les personnes étrangères présentes
sur sur notre territoire vous afficherez
la fermeté propre à votre ambition
politique mais la réalité on la connaît
vous n'allez qu'amplifier le désordre et
la précarité quand la machine
administrative broie arbitrairement par
son organisation ou plutôt son incurie
la vie des personnes étrangère elle
alimente aussi le désarroi des agents
des préfectures ou des travailleurs
sociaux pour autant est-ce que ce texte
va réduire le contentieux le Conseil
d'État dans son avis douche un peu vos
espoirs la réforme ne permettra pas par
elle-même de limiter la substantielle et
croissante du contentieux des étrangers
dans l'activité de la juridiction
administrative je cite ce tour de vis
législatif supplémentaire va en revanche
impacter la vie des personnes pourtant
installées depuis longtemps sur notre
territoire la loi prévoit ainsi des
capacités élargies de lever les
protections particulières pour appel
cette protection vise à empêcher de
prononcer des qtf à l'encontre des
étrangers qui sont soit père ou mère
d'un enfant français mineur résidant en
France marié à un ou une Fran français
qui résident en France depuis plus de 10
ans ou qui justifi d'un domicile
régulier en France depuis la veille de
leur 13 ans pour toutes ces personnes
donc une qtf pourra être prononcé non
pas comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui si
elles sont condamnées à plus de an de
prisons mais si elles ont été condamnées
par un délit passible de 50
d'emprisonnement au-delà de la
distorsion évidente de l'égalité face à
la loi de toutes et tous un étranger est
ainsi reconnis coupable au maximum de la
peine encourue c'est évidemment la
logique de la double peine qui fait son
retour complet ici durciss toujours au
sein du texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui celle fois-ci cela concerne
la santé des personnes étrangères la
majorité sénatoriale au Sénat propose et
on ne sait plus trop si c'est avec votre
assentiment personnel monsieur le
ministre de remplacer l'aide médicale
d'État par une aide médicale d'urgence
un accord vaut visiblement bien la mise
en danger de la santé des Français comme
des étrangers les arguments de la
majorité sénatorial ici on les connaît
l'ame coûte cher et son maintien
constituerait un appel d'air à
l'immigration illégale peu importe si
chaque année plusieurs collègues
rappellent que ces deux arguments sont
faux le coût des soins couverts par la
me et du dispositif des soins urgents et
vitaux ne représente que 0,4 % des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie en
France et seulement 51 % des personnes
qui en sont éligibles demandent à
recourir à laame pour des raisons
comptables mais surtout idéologiques on
fragilise la santé des personnes mais
aussi ça paraî évident de toute la
population enfin les débats qui ont
entouré ce texte ont évidemment c'est
presque devenu une coutume ici toucher
les associations et les bénévoles cette
fois évidemment celles et ceux qui font
vivre nos valeurs républicaine de
fraternité enant en accompagnant les
personnes migrantes dans leur parcours
vous-même monsieur le ministre vous en
êtes pris directement à la simade
récemment mais ce sont toutes les
associations d'aide aux personnes
migrantes qui sont entravées dans leur
action et harcelé par nos forces de
police je l'ai même moi-même constaté
lors d'une maraude avec les équipes de
Médecins du Monde mais ce constat est
largement documenté au-delà de ma
personne ces associations visent
simplement au respect du droit à la
protection des plus fragiles ce sont les
vigies permanentes qui nous alertent sur
l'indignité de nos politiques
migratoires et P au manque
d'investissement de l'État une fois
détaillé le catalogue des mesures de
contrôle de fermeté et de répression il
est temps de parler d'intégration la
carotte après le bâton mais la carotte
est bien maigre et c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire penchons-nous d'abord sur
l'intégration par la langue française
nous pourrions imaginer cette
intégration se manifeste par un
renforcement de l'accès aux formation et
au cours mais la finalité est toute
autre le niveau de langue devient un
outil d'exclusion un motif de refus de
titre une aversion même des des objectif
fixés la mesure a pour objectif
d'inciter les étrangers d'inciter les
étrangers qui souhaitent demeurer
durablement sur le territoire français à
se mobiliser davantage pour leur
apprentissage de français de manière à
favoriser leur intégration en France
nous dit l'exposé des motifs de votre
texte l' l'incitation par le refus de
carte de séjour drôle de carotte cette
mesure l' incitation a tellement plu à
la droite qu'elle l'a rendu plus
expluante encore sans même se préoccuper
de renforcer cours et formation alors
certes nous pouvions nous pouvons y
venir nous aurions voulu voter l'article
3 de ce texte nous avons toujours
défendu la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papierers lorsqu'on
travaille ici que souvent on cotise ici
il est logique de bénéficier des mêmes
droits que les travailleurs d'ici il est
vrai qu'au début du texte Olivier Duss
vous accompagnait il brille par son
absence aujourd'hui il a disparu depuis
quelques semaines tout comme a disparu
la valeur travail du logiciel de la
droite sénatoriale qui en fait le casus
Bell indépassable ou il faut s'y faire
désormais la droite dite républicaine
pré préfère donc le travail au noir et
l'exploitation des clandestins mais même
vous monsieur le ministre vous exigez
tout de même une bonne période de
clandestinité dans l'article 3 en amont
de la demande de Votre titre de séjour
métier en tension il faudra que la
personne étrangère sans droit nitite
vive dans l'ombre esquive les contrôles
pendant 3 ans et travaille sans droit
réel pendant 8 mois pour obtenir son
titre lui permettant de travailler
légalement l'égalité des droits ajustée
par la loi du marché et les hasards de
la vie soit si cela permet d'avoir
d'autres portes de régularisation que la
circulaire dit Vals nous pourrions nous
laisser convaincre dans les jours qui
viennent mes chers collègues vous allez
vous allez jouer l'avenir de milliers de
travailleuses et de travailleurs dans un
calcul des plus cyniques une une autre
voie et pourtant possible pas moins
ferme pas moins républicaine la crise
ukrainienne et les moyens exceptionnels
déployés dans un temps record en matière
d'hébergement nous l'ONS montré mais
cela demande une approche radicalement
différente cela démange qu'on accepte un
changement de rapport dans les liens
entre l'État les collectivités et les
les acteurs de la solidarité pourtant
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui avec
une loi dans la ligée des dizaines
d'autres qui l'ont précédé qui ne répond
pas aux enjeux actuels en termees de
migration et
d'intégration une fois de plus ce projet
de loi passe à côté de la réalité vécu
par les personnes étrangères un texte
qui va dégrader la situation au lieu de
l'améliorer l'insertion économique et
sociale l'accès au droit la formation
l'accès au soins la protection des
mineurs bref la garantie des conditions
d'un accueil digne demande de sortir de
cette approche centrée sur les questions
sécuritaires elle demande une approché
sur les parcours d'hommes et de femmes
comme celles et ceux en tribune
aujourd'hui sur leurs aspirations et
notre
humanité prend une direction
radicalement inverse c'est pourquoi je
vous demande de voter cette motion de
rejet merci quel est l'avis de la
commission le suspens sera relativement
limité il sera bien entendu défavorable
peut-être dire à notre collègue que nous
avons tous écoué avec beaucoup
d'attention que il nous a indiqué tout
ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire et vous
avez détaillé tout ce que vous reprochez
dans ce texte ou dans le travail
d'amendement réalisé vous nous avez dit
à aucun moment ce qu'il fallait faire et
comment traiter ces sujets sinon en
quelques secondes par la référence
à la solution ukrainienne ce qui ét
quand même un peu une forme de pirouette
intellectuelle vous nous avez également
indiqué que il
manquait une étude d'impact que la
mesure des phénomènes n'avait pas été
défin je pense quand même que l'ensemble
des éléments qui se situent qui se
déroulent dans notre société et les
chiffres que j'ai rappelé quant au
nombre de personnes irrégulières sur
territoire quant au nombre de demandes
d'asile et cetera euh représentait bien
une objectivation du sujet par ailleurs
vous avez ce qui est tout à fait normal
évoquer le détail des éléments et nous
aurons
l'occasion si euh votre motion est est
rejetée de pouvoir en débattre peut-être
un dernier élément sur ce que vous avez
appelé le la disparition de l'idéal
européen c'est un sujet auquel je suis
sensible et pour ma génération qui a été
construite intellectuellement avec cette
idal européen c'est effectivement un
sujet et vous l'avez entendu dans
l'intervention du ministre tout à
l'heure
la la manière de mobiliser aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des P dans les pays de
l'Union Européen sur ces questions est
un sujet douloureux tout le monde
préféait que les solutions soient d'ors
et déjà soient d'ors et déjà présent
peut-être aussi vous dire que le débat
que vous nous présentez un peu comme
franco-français n'est pas si
franco-français que cela puisque en
réalité il se déroule sur l'ensemble du
continent européen et que quelque part
les discussions que nous avons en cette
fin d' après-midi vous les avez
également en Allemagne ne parlons pas de
de l'Italie mais je je partage en tout
cas avec vous l'idée que nous devons
reconstituer un narratif ou voire même
un idéal européen vous comprendrez que
la vie soit négatif
merci l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
défavorable il y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote je n'en vois point
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
question préalable adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion qui est pour l'adoption de
cette question préalable avis
contraire n pas
adopté nous allons passer à la
discussion demandant le renvoi en
commission et
elle a été déposée par notre collègue
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie les membbres
du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républi
je vais lui donner la
parole vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames madame la ministre
monsieur le le président de la
commission madame et et Monsieur le le
rapporteur chers collègues je reprendrai
pour débuter mon propos le propos de
notre collègue Philippe boncarer le
retour du
Parlement nous savons depuis quelques
semaines depuis quelques mois que le
Parlement ne fonctionne pas de manière
comment dire idéale nous le voyons à
l'Assemblée nous en sommes 13e
engagement de responsabilité du
gouvernement motion de censure mais dans
ce paysage parlementaire il y a un îo de
sérieux de robustesse euh parlementaire
et législative et euh de travaux
accomplis ce qui n'empêche pas
d'ailleurs les affrontements c'est le
Sénat et donc cette motion de renvoi je
vais tenter de vous convaincre de la
voter parce que je pense qu'il ne faut
pas malmener notre démocratie
parlementaire et que c'est pour cela
qu'il faut la voter et que ce serait
l'honneur du Sénat pour trois raisons la
première monsieur le ministre vous
n'êtes pas prêt
ce texte a connu un parcours pour le
moins chaotique il a été adopté il y a 1
an au Conseil des ministres il est venu
une première fois devant la commission
des lois le 15 mars dernier inscrit à
l'ordre du jour puis désinscrit
8 mois plus tard le voilà en séance
entre-temps vous avez produit un nombre
d'annonces successives non toujours
suivi des faits d'ailleurs
vous vouliez expulser tous ceux qui
manifestent une adhésion à une idéologie
djihadiste radicale un autre jour
expulser tous les fichiers s un troisème
jour augmenté à 18 mois la rétention qui
était aujourd'hui de 90
jours vous êtes aujourd'hui bien seul il
faut bien le dire même si je note qu'une
de vos collègues a estimé devoir venir
au banc du gouvernement monsieur du sopt
a disparu et euh alors qu'il est
signataire du projet de loi le garde des
sauts est momentanément empêché mais
nous aurons l'occasion de demander sa
présence puisque nous avons compris
qu'il pouvait faire plusieurs choses à
la fois et notamment siégé ici sur le
banc du gouvernement lorsque les
articles qui le concernent viendront en
séance vous avez depuis lors déposé 28
amendements sans avis du Conseil d'État
évidemment sans étude d'impact et donc
aujourd'hui à l'évidence la suc de vos
annonces montre que ce texte n'est pas
abouti ensuite je le dirai au président
buffet la commission n'est pas prête
tout d'abord la commission a adopté un
texte singulièrement modifié composé
d'un tiers de membres de cette
commission qui ne sont plus parmi nous
donc lorsque nos collègu Jourda et boncè
s'expriment je ne sais pas au nom de
quel collègue il s'expriment puisque'un
tiers d'entre eux n'est plus des nôtres
ensuite nous avons noté lors de l'examen
par cette commission c'est un fait assez
atypique me semble-il que sur deux
articles majeurs les articles 3 et les
articles 4 la commission n'avait pas
d'avis les rapporteurs n'étaient pas
d'accord j'indiquerai d'ailleurs au
ministre quelque chose qui m'a paru
extrêmement étrange au point qu'il a
fallu que je vérifie avec mes collègues
si je ne Métais pas Tromp dans votre
discours de présentation du texte pas un
mot sur ces articles difficiles et j'ai
trouvé très étrange que rien n'a été
dessiné de l'accord possible qui était
semble-t-il envisagé je dis cela parce
que je lis le journal et non parce que
cela se passe en commission nous avons
vu ensuite arriver 28 amendements du
Gouvernement puis 32 amendements du
rapporteur aujourd'hui des rapporteurs
aujourd'hui même et c'est pour vous dire
que je ne suis pas la seule je pense à
trouver que la Commission n'est pas
totalement n'a pas totalement fait
aboutir ses travaux c'est que le
ministre de l'Intérieur a estimer devoir
initier une réunion délocalisée de la
Commission dans la salle à manger de
beauau ce qui prouve bien et ce à cette
occasion le président retaot et moi ce
n'est pas coutumier nous étons d'accord
avec le fait que les travaux
parlementaires se tenaient au Parlement
et non dans cette salle à manger même si
on m'a dit que le déjeuner était
excellent le trè point qui fait que
cette de renvoi était je n'étais pas là
Monsieur le Ministre donc vous étiez
sans doute en très bonne compagnie le
trème point qui mène à ce
que cette motion de droit voie doit être
votée c'est que le Sénat n'est pas
prêt nous avons noté que le groupe LR a
déposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui de mon point de
vue fait système avec le texte dont nous
débattons
aujourd'hui pour ma part j'aurais trou
trouz logique que le projet de loi
d'aujourd'hui soit débattu après la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
porte en grande partie sur les sujets
d'immigration et donc il me semble que
si le groupe LR qui est très important
ici voulait un travail cohérent il
demanderait l'inscription de ce projet
de loi après l'examen de la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
ensuite on note une certaine instabilité
au Sénat on a l'habitude des choses bien
faites on arrive en séance la majorité
sénatoriale certes composée de deux
groupes essentiels je ne veux vexer
personne travaille ensemble l'opposition
s'oppose manière la plus efficace
possible mais je dois dire que le
résultat de notre opposition est souvent
assez
relatif mais dans le cas présent les
articles 3 et 4 et la me font l'objet
semble-il de grandes difficultés entre
vous au point qu'à l'heure où nous
parlons nous ne savons absolument rien
de ce ce que vous
entendez ce sur quoi vous entendez
délibérer au point que l'on me dit ça
restera entre nous mais oui Roger
carouci il y a débat que vous pourriez
demander la réserve des articles 3 et 4
afin de pouvoir en débattre vendredi je
trouve que c'est une excellente idée
pour nos collègue moi personnellement
j'ai prévu d'être là toute la semaine
mais je l'indique à certains réservez
votre vendredi car c'est ce jour-là que
le débat peut-être aura lieu donc nous
le voyons tout cela n'est pas très
sérieux et très instable alors en
conclusion
je me suis demandé pourquoi le
gouvernement s'obstinait et pourquoi le
ministre de l'Intérieur s'obstinait à
vouloir présenter ce projet de loi est
arrivé le drame
d'aras et à partir du drame d'aras nous
avons entendu le ministre de l'Intérieur
s'appuyer sur ce fait terrible pour
expliquer que ce projet de loi était
indispensable et de manière un petit peu
excessive estimer que si ce projet de
loi avait été en vigueur le drame d'
race aurait pu peut-être être
évité je regrette ces propos
pourquoi je pense que d'une part le
ministre aurait dû noter et soutenir ses
services car dans le drame d'arace les
services de police ont fonctionné il se
trouve
que il se trouve que la sécurité totale
n'existe pas et que lorsque vous
indiquez que si ce projet de loi avait
été voté haras ne se serait pas produit
ce n'est pas exact et donc vous utilisez
et instrumentalisez quasiment cette ce
terrible ce terrible meurtre euh pour
expliquer qu'il faut voter ce projet
comme une sorte d'assurance que vous
voulez construire pour éviter d'être
mise en cause ultérieurement peut-être
lorsque un drame analogue pourrait se
reproduire donc au bénéfice de
l'ensemble de ces constats
d'impréparation de manquement et de
difficultés à déterminer une position
stable sur un sujet sérieux nous
souhaitons que la Commission puisse
retravailler afin que dans les jours qui
viennent nous puissions proposer un
texte qui soit à la hauteur de ces
ambitions quel est l'avis
de la commission monsieur
rapporteur l'avis monsieur le Président
sera également défavorable merci bien
sûr à Madame de lagonterie d'avoir
débuter son propos par un éloge du
sérieux du travail sénatorial mais vous
savez tous que quand un propos commence
par des félicitations euh la suite n'est
pas de même nature et cela bien sûr été
le le cas quand au fait de savoir si
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur est
prêt ça ou pas ça c'est à lui qu'il
appartiendra de répondre sur le nombre
d'amendements du gouvernement 28 je ne
pourrais pas lui en faire le reproche
puisqu'il y en a 32 de la part des
rapporteurs sur euh la le fait qu'un
tiers des des collègues euh est été
qu'il y a eu une modification pardon
avec le renouvellement sénatorial dans
la composition de notre assemblée vous
avez bien sûr raison tout en attirant
votre attention sur qu'il est fait qu'il
existe une continuité de l'État mais
qu'il existe également une continuité du
par du Parlement ou plus exactement je
crois que le terme institutionnel est
dire que l'assemblée est permanente vous
dire enfin sur la référence au drame
d'aras que je ne crois pas que les
disposition que nous examinons soit des
dispositions qui s'inscrivent dans ce
que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure l'aire du
temps je récuse en tout cas dans le
travail des rapporteurs dans le travail
que nous avons pu mener monsieur le
Président buffet dans le cadre de la
commission des lois je récuse nous
soyons sur un texte d'émotion nous
essayons de trouver des solutions de
moyen et de long terme d'où la demande
de rejet de la motion
présentée merci l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi madame de La Gonterie
d'abord de de vous dire je TR je trouve
le manque total de de délicatesse
d'attaque de Monsieur DUP morti qui ne
peut se défendre dans cet hémicycle et
je pense queon devrait plus se
poser n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas la
prochaine fois à être courageuse devant
lui et pas quand il n'est pas là je
pense que ce serait une première chose
voilà je je je vous je vous ai écouté
j'ai même souffert à vous écouter
souffrez un peu que je vous réponde j'ai
l'impression que Madame
oui oui je sais je sais je sais mais ce
n'est pas fini ça durera jusqu'à
vendredi au moins et j'ai tout mon temps
personnellement madame la sénatrice je
suis à disposition du Parlement j'ai
l'impression que vous vous êtes en en
fait en train de nous exprimer allez je
vais le dire une forme de de regret
voilà peut-être même d'ailleurs vous
cherchez à vous rattraper vous dites
qu'on est trop dur mais mais madame de
La Gonterie vous apportenez une majorité
qui a souhaité la déchéance de
nationalité non non non mais je je non
non mais bah moi j'ai j'étais
parlementaire à l'époque nous étions
dans un hémicycle à Versailles j'ai
entendu président Hollande qui
d'ailleurs président Hollande qui début
novembre je vousour je vous encourage à
écouter le président Hollande qui début
novembre dans l'émission quotidien
d'ailleurs je vous passerai la band
disait que la loi que le gouvernement
proposait était une loi qu'il fallait
discuter et peut-être même adopter bon
donc non mais je constate que le
président Hollande n'est pas sur ses
bomes et que désormais après rejeter un
certain nombre de personnes vous rejetez
y compris même le président Hollande ce
qui vous sans doute vous pousse non
seulement à ne pas voir que vous étiez
donc favorable chez les socialistes à
déchérance de nationalité maintenant
vous dites que le gouvernement est trop
dur bah écoutez c'est un président
socialiste qui l'a proposé alors
peut-être que Monsieur Holland était pas
un président
socialiste bien bien donc écoutez vous
ferez le procès du président Hollande
plus tard mais quand même je vrais
iessayer vous le dire voilà ça fait même
rire l'hémicycle à dr droite regardez on
arrive en 3h on arrive à trouver déjà
des motifs des motifs de de d'humour
avec vous Madame de La Gonterie
deièmement vous semblez regretter vous
dites il y a trop de lois vousz vous
avez voté trois madame de La Gonterie en
5 ans la loi de décembre 2012
La la la loi de décembre 2012 la loi de
juillet 2015 la loi de mars 2016 ou
d'ailleurs je vais signé que dans la loi
de mars 2016 du du ministre cas9 qui
autre candidat putatif de la sociale
démocratie que vous soutenez prévoyez et
je pense que c'est un point important là
aussi des mesures extrêmement fortes
contre les étrangers qui étaient qui
faisaient des qui étai en responsabilité
d'actes terroristes suite notamment aux
attentats horribles qu' a connu la
France là vous n'avez pas fait le procès
de suite à un attentat que le
gouvernement a légiféré c'est bien
normal que le gouvernement et que le
Parlement réfléchissent et voit ce qui a
pu dfonctionner troisème regret madame
de La Gonterie moi mes services je les
soutiens madame de La
Gonterie les policiers je les soutiens
ce qui est sûr c'est que les services
étrangers quand vous étiez en
responsabilité avaient fait leur travail
avec cette famille tchenne radicalisée
c'est pardon je vous le dire votre
gouvernement et la pression de vos amis
et notamment y compris les associations
qui vous soutiennent qu'on fait libérer
cette famille vous avez fait pression
sur les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur vous n'avez pas respecté le
travail du préfet de Bretagne vous
n'avez pas respecté le travail de la
police aux frontières et sur Inquisition
politique vous avez demandé au droit
français de reculer vous avez fait
libérer vous et vos amis cette famille
si vous devlez faire le réquisitoire de
quelqu'un c'était réquisitoire de la
pression politique que la gauche a jadis
appuyé en effet quand monsieur Vals été
mise à l'intérieur puisqueen effet les
service ministintérieur avaiit très bien
travaillé et s'il y avait en effit un
drame dans la race madame de La Gonterie
c'est d'avoir soutenu cette proposition
de libération de ces
[Applaudissements]
personne il y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote je n'en vois point
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la motion
de renvoi à la commission si la motion
était adoptée le renvoi du texte à la
commission serait ordonné qui est
favorable à son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas
adopté nous allons passer à la suite de
la discussion générale et nous allons
donner la parole à Monsieur Stéphane
Ravier pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe et Monsieur
ravier dispose de 3
minutes vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre M chers collègues plus de 2
millions d'étrangers sont entrés sur le
territoire français sous la macronie
soit l'équivalent de la ville de Paris
selon l'Observatoire de l'immigration et
de la démographie entre 700000 et 900000
clandestins vivent sur notre sol c'est
l'équivalent de la population de
Marseille et 95 % des qtf ne sont pas
exécutés
423000 clandestins bénéficient de l'aide
médicale d'État c'est près de 20000
bénéficiairees supplémentaires en
seulement 6 mois cela nous coûte
1illard200 million d'euros par an selon
l'assemblée des département de France il
y aurait plus de 40000 prétendus mineurs
non accompagnés pour un coût annuel
moyen de 50000 € par mineur un coût de 2
milliards d'euros par an à la charge du
contribuable français par ailleurs selon
l'INC sur les 2600000 Algériens vivants
sur notre sol 42 % sont chômeurs ou
inactifs tout en bénéficiant de la
panoplie des aides sociales dont il ne
sont pas contributeurs alors que la
France n'est plus un eldorado mais un
Rado l'immigration coûte coûte selon
l'OCDE 35 milliards d'euros finances
publiques françaises chaque année soit
l'équivalent du double des économies de
la réforme des retraites réalisées
jusqu'en 2027 cette immigration
également un coût sécuritaire effarant
les étrangers représentent 10 % de la
population totale de la France mais 25 %
de la population carcérale et sont
responsables de 50 % de la délinquence
et de la criminalité la réalité est
encore plus scandaleuse car ces chiffres
ne prennent pas en compte les
binationaux qui comme Mohamed Mera a
assassiné des enfants juifs parce que
juifs et des soldats français parce que
français parmi le flot des faux réfugiés
et vrai clandestin on compte les
terroristes du Bataclan l'assassin de
Lur et moral à Marseille de Samuel
paatti de Nadine Vincent et Simone dans
la basilique de Nice de Lola de
Dominique Bernard de Fabienne très
récemment à Lille la natalité française
s'effondre pendant que la natalité
exogène explose chez nous plus près d'un
tiers des enfants nés en 2021 ont au
moins un parent r né à l'étranger cette
réalité de la submersion migratoire et
de la balance démographique à un nom le
grand remplacement un grand remplacement
culturel et civilisationnel nous sommes
passés de 100 mosquées en 1970 à 3000
aujourd'hui si bien que la vie de
certains quartiers de certaines villes
de France est rythmé aux heures de la
prière et des us et coutumes islamiques
et que les manifestations de soutien au
Hamas se multiplient à travers le pays
au cris de ala b motivé par la haine des
Juifs et la détestation de la France le
voilà votre bilan suicidaire de votre
politique d'immigration mes chers
collègues car vous êtes tous responsa de
cette folie de ce désastre à gauche pour
être passé du parti de l'étranger au
parti des étrangers bien sûr on s'en
félicite à droite après 30 ans de
naïveté de dénis mais aussi de soutien
et de petit calculs électoraux on s'en
inquiète enfin alors plutôt que de
vouloir sauver les apparences je vous
conjure de sauver la France ce sont les
Français eux-mêmes qui vous le demandent
alors mes chers collègues j'en appelle à
votre courage et à l'Union ensemble
faisons de cette 30e loi sur
l'immigration la première et unique loi
sur la non immigration pour que vive
vive la France française dans une Europe
européenne
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Danny wetteblade pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
territoires
parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président la Commission des lois
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers
collègues il y a plus de 30 ans François
mitteran estiméit que les caps maximales
d'accueil des immigrés en France avait
été atteinte dès
1970 ne pas réussir à gérer la question
migratoire depuis des décennies apparaît
aux yeux de concitoyens comme la
démonstration de l' puissance de l'État
en 2022 les franchissements illégaux de
la frontière extérieur on bondit de 64 %
par rapport à 2021 ils sont encore en
augmentation
2023 les états y compris au sein de
Frontex ne déi pas suffisant des moyens
pour faire face à cet
afflux l'immigration légale connaît elle
aussi une forte progression au sein de
pays des pays de l'OCDE 300000 immigrés
permanents en France pour la seule année
2022 ce chiffre bat les record des 15
dernières années malgré cela certains
continuent à appeler à ouvrir grand nos
portes prétendant ainsi défendre les
droits de l'homme et la voie du peuple
cela est illusoire et cela est même
dangereux ilillusir d'abord car pas les
moyens d'accueillir tout le monde dans
des condition décent digne dangereux
ensuite parce que plus de% de no
concitoyens considèent qu'il a trop
d'immigration et d'immigr en France
compatriot ne souhaite pas l'immigration
massive consci de cela nous avons aussi
gardé en mémoire les conséquences
politiques des vagues migratoires depuis
2015 en Europe la Grèce aurait procédé à
à des refoulements illégaux la Pologne a
géré avec fermeté la crise provoquée par
la Biélorussie la Hongrie a construit un
mur de barbelé le Royaume-Uni et le
Danemark ont même renvoyé envisagé
d'envoyer des migrants au Rwanda la
France n'a jamais recouru à de tels
procédés les crises géop politiques
s'enchaînent au Moyen-Orient au Sahel en
Afrique subsaharienne et demain dans le
Golfe de Guinée il a craind que les flux
migratoires vers l'Europe continent de
s'accroître bien encadré l'immigration
peut-être une chance une chance pour
nous tous lorsqu'elle aboutit à de
l'intégration en revanche prétendre
qu'une immigration insuffisamment
maîtrisé n'est pas encore source de
difficulté et malhonnête notre nation
fait face à un déficit de cohésion
l'accueil d'étranger désir de nous
rejoindre ne peut pas se faire au prix
de l'affion de nos
nous voulons absolument reprendre le
contrôle le projet que nous voyons
aujourd'hui que nous examinons y
contribue il aggrave en premier lieu les
sanctions contre les passeurs tous ceux
qui facilitent l'immigration illégale
sur notre territoire les sanctions
prévues sont lourdes et disuadives elles
devront être appliquées le texte
renforce aussi les poss d'expulsion des
étrangers
dangereux aucun de nos compatriotes ne
peut plus comprendre ni accepter que de
tels individus se maintiennent sur notre
territoire ce qui représent une menace
grave pour notre public ceux qui ont été
condamnés pour des faits illégaux
infraction à la loi pénale ceux-là n'ont
pas leur place en France ces mesures
protégeront davantage no citoyens et
permettront une meilleure intégration
des étrangers respectueux de nos
lois dans le même esprit nous nous
félicitons que l'engagement républicain
soit remis au S de politique migratoire
l'égalité femme homme la laïcité le
respect de la liberté des valeurs et des
symboles de République ne sont pas des
éléments négociables ils appartient à
ceux qui veulent venir dans notre pays
d'en embrasser la culture et les
valeurs le projet renforce également les
exigences la maîtrise de la langue
française c'est l'une des clés
d'intégration dans not société l'autre
clé bien sûr est le travail
l'article 3 est sans doute le plus
polémique du texte nous attendons des
débats à venir qui nous permettent de
trouver un point d'équilibre entre d'une
part des situations d'ors et déjà
existantes dans notre pays et la Cé de
pas créer non plus un appel d'air
d'autre part l'histoire de notre pays et
sa démographie nous conduisent àer une
politique d'accueil maîtrisée nous
devons absolument veiller à l'cion des
lois que nous votons et à celle des
décisions rendues par la justice et par
nos tribunaux
nous appelons de nos vœux une politique
d'immigration choisie nous souons que
les immigrés admis à VI dans le pays
travail et qu'il soi accueillli en
fonction des besoins de notre économie
et de leur volonté de s'intégrer
c'estàdire de notre société c'est cela
quiille intégration parmi les besoins de
sociétés se trouvve bien sûr les métiers
en tenstion les métiers médicossoal le
projet de loi prévoit plusieurs mesures
à même de soulanger le manque de
personnel il y a aussi aussi les patrons
que l'on a peut-être appelé patron voyou
mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres qui
veulent régulariser leur personnel qui
sont là présents depuis plusieurs années
et qui ne savaient même pas qu' étaaient
en in irrégulière la question migratoire
concerne tant la France que ses
partenaires européens seul les grands
ensembles peuvent répondre efficacement
au grands défis de notre temps dans le
casadre de la diffion de sa politique
migratoire l'Union européenne doit
travailler à soulager les États membres
qui sont en première ligne la France en
fait partie avec nos partenaires nous
devons ensuite négocier avec plus de
fermeté des accords de réadmission et
enfin de renforcer nos capacités de
reconduire hors des frontières pays
d'origine vers le pays d'origine si nous
ne parvenons pas à garder efficacement
nos frontières si nous échouons à faire
correspondre l'immigration aux besoins
de nos sociétés les Européens sont
condamnés à l'indivision et donc à
l'impuissance ce texte nécessaire et
attendu cons une première réponse aux
attentes de nos concitoyens nous devons
lors d'examen prochain du budget veillez
à élever nos moyens à la hauteur de nos
ambitions le groupe Les Indépendants
soutient l'adoption de ce projet de loi
je vous
remercie
merci je vais maintenant donner la
parole à notre collègue Isabelle Floren
pour le groupe de l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste
la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames madames et monsieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues ça y
est nous allons enfin examiner ce projet
de loi immigration dont 98 % du texte a
été approuvé en mars et cette attente
nous aura permis de mesurer à quel point
notre droit ne nous permet pas de faire
face passe efficacement à l'un des
principaux défis politiques qui est
devant nous en effet pas un mois
malheureusement sans qu'une actualité ne
fasse état de délits commis par une
personne qui n'aurait pas dû être sur
notre sol ou que l'on soit confronté à
ces images de camp de migrants sur
l'espace public malgré les très nombreux
textes législatifs qui se sont succédés
depuis plus de 30 ans la politique
migratoire laisse apparaître une forme
d'impuissance de fatalité que état ne
parviendrait pas à gérer pourtant on ne
peut pas faire le reproche à votre
gouvernement de ne rien faire en la
matière monsieur le ministre mais la
réalité quotidienne notamment en matière
d'immigration illégale est souvent
décourageante si l'on en croit l'exposé
des motifs votre projet de loi n'est pas
je cite une couche supplémentaire de
sédimentation législative nous
l'espérons tous effectivement que ce
n'est pas le cas une chose est sûre sans
refaire l'invent de l'ensemble des
mesures votre texte vise bel et bien
l'ensemble des aspects de notre
politique migratoire en passant de
l'immigration économique à l'asile et à
la simplification de son contentieux aux
mesures en faveur de l'intégration et de
la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale malgré tout cela a été rappelé
par nos rapporteurs votre texte manquait
d'ambition sur certaines thématiques
notre commission des lois dont je salue
la qualité du travail a largement étaufé
votre projet aussi bien s'agissant du
renforcement de la politique
d'intégration que de la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale je reviendrai
dans quelques instants sur plusieurs
aspects de ce texte mais une remarque
plus générale tout d'abord le défi
migratoire ne concerne pas que notre
pays vous l'avez dit il concerne
l'ensemble de nos pays voisins et de nos
voisins européens et nous ne sommes pas
les plus mal lottis dans cette dans
cette situation en tout cas l'Italie et
et la Grèce pour n'en citer que deux
sont quotidiennement bien plus exposés
que nous par facilité certains sont
tentés de dire ah oui mais vous
comprenez c'est surtout un problème
européen et il est vain de modifier sans
fin notre législation nationale bien sûr
que le problème est européen mais ce
n'est certainement pas une raison pour
attendre que la solution Vienne
exclusivement de l'Union européenne nous
devons à la fois porter des évolutions
efficaces dans notre droit interne et
convaincre nos voisins d'adopter des
solutions à l'échelle européenne mais
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre nous avons
besoin de règles européennes
ensuite sommes-nous parvenus avec les
mesures que nous examinons aujourd'hui à
un plafond de verre de ce que nous
pouvons faire en droit constitutionnel
constant sur plusieurs aspects il me
semble que c'est le cas je ne doute pas
que la discussion des amendements
amènera nos rapporteurs à rappeler ce
cadre et à signaler que plusieurs propos
i pouvant paraître intéressantes sont
contraires à la Constitution nous sommes
conscients de ces limites
constitutionnelles c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis les travaux de la
commission en mars dernier notre groupe
a proposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à aménager la
norme suprême en matière d'asile le
texte que nous avons déposé prévoit que
les demandes d'asile soient présentées
non plus à l'arrivée sur le territoire
national mais auprès de nos ambassades
et consulats
nous pensons qu'il faut donc
radicalement faire évoluer notre système
pour pouvoir continuer à protéger vite
ce qui sont réellement en danger sur ce
sujet il en va de l'honneur de la France
c'est pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
opposés par principe à faire évoluer
notre Constitution sur ces questions
mais dans le respect des exigences
conventionnelles en effet peut-on
accepter demain de déroger à la
hiérarchie des normes principes cardinal
de notre état de droitut faut-il
envisager des cas dans lesquels
l'autorité des traités serait remise en
cause par rapport à celle de la loi
interne nous y sommes défavorables si
certains aspects d'un traité nous
semblent inadaptés négotionons leurs
modifications si des dispositions
communautaires sont devenues
inopportunes travaillons avec nos
voisins pour
l'échanger puisque nos collègues etire
nous y invite nous aurons ce débat dans
l'hémicycle au mois de décembre pour
leur je reviens au projet loi notre
commission des lois a apporté de
nombreuses améliorations au texte et je
me concentrerai sur certaines d'entre
elles l'article 1er vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur introduit une
innovation majeure elle prévoit la tenue
d'un débat annuel au Parlement sur les
orientation pluriannuelle en matière
migratoire mais surtout à l'issue du
débat le Parlement déterminera le nombre
des étrangers admis à s'installer
durablement en France pour chacune des
catégories de séjour à l'exception de
l'asile à travers cette disposition la
représentation nationale vaoir va
pouvoir chaque année orienter la
politique migratoire de notre pays une
excellente mesure permettant d'associer
députés sénateurs et gouvernement dans
un débat public pour une fois nous ne
subirons pas l'actualité nous la ferons
la Commission s'est également attachée à
renforcer la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale deux articles du texte sont
malheureusement euh de sortie de
l'anonymat malheureusement après
l'assassinat ignob du professeur
Dominique Bernard enseignant au groupe
scolaire Garn gambeta à haras les
articles 9 et 10 nos rapporteurs avaient
déjà profondément modifié ces articles
relactif aux protection permettant
d'empêcher des mesures d'expulsion ou le
prononcer d'interdiction sur du
territoire français nous avons tous été
heurté par le profil de l'agresseur du
professeur et de celui d'une partie de
sa famille total radicalisé il nous faut
aller plus loin encore et faciliter la
levée des protections absolues et
relatives pour des individus qui sont
une telle menace pour la sécurité
publique mais sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres ne cédons pas à la tentation
d'adopter des dispositifs dont nous
savons qu'ils seront censurés par le
Conseil constitutionnel nous n'avons
rien à y gagner
impossible évidemment de faire l'impasse
sur l'article le plus célèbre de ce
texte le fameux article article 3 nous
tenons au préalable à rappeler que nous
ne comprenons pas du tout
l'effervescence suscitée par cette
disposition sur les métiers en tension
elle ne mérite sûrement pas les
réactions très excessives qu'elle
suscite y a-t-il aujourd'hui des
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
travaillent légalement dans notre pays
oui bien sûr sont-ils parfois
régularisés au bout d'un certain temps
de présence et de travail sur le
territoire national
oui bien sûr autrement dit le sujet de
cet article n'est pas nouveau et il ne
serait pas juste de prétendre le
contraire l'innovation majeure de
l'article 3 réside dans la création d'un
titre de séjour de plein droit pour
qu'une personne travaillant dans notre
pays depuis plus de 8 mois au cours des
pour une personne qui travaillerait
depuis plus de 8 mois au cours des deux
dernières années notre groupe a
longuement débattu de cette disposition
un élément centrale a toujours fait
consensus niz la situation de ces
travailleurs sans papier qui travaillent
parfois depuis des années sur notre sol
souvent dans des métiers pénibles ne
résoudra pas le problème soyons clair
ces personnes sont le plus souvent non
expulsable ils sont sur le territoire
depuis trop longtemps ils sont intégrés
ont souvent une famille inutile donc de
venir les voir grossir la catégorie de
ce qu'on appelle les niis ni expulsable
ni régularisable mais faut-il pour
autant créer un nouveau type de titre de
séjour nous avons finalement considérer
que ce n'était pas la bonne option le
plus efficace est de conserver comme
aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'appréciation
des des préfets dans une gestion des
dossiers au cas par cas c'est ce que
prévoit l'amendement que nous vous
présenterons il prévoit aussi et surtout
de modifier le régime applicable en
matière d'autorisation de travail
cela a été rappelé un salarié sans
papier qui souhaite régulariser sa
situation doit recueillir l'accord de
son employeur pour pouvoir présenter sa
demande de titre de séjour en préfecture
il ne nous paraît pas pertinent de
maintenir ainsi un salarié étranger dans
la dépendance de son employeur c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre amendement
prévoit aussi la suppression de cet
accord préalable une telle rédaction de
l'article 3 nous semble pragmatique et
responsable ni d'appel d'air ni des n de
réalité nous espérons que celle-ci sera
finalement partagée par tous nous sommes
également favorable à un dispositif qui
permette d'assouplir l'accès plus rapide
au marché du travail pour les demandeurs
d'asile qui sont susceptibles d'obtenir
la protection de la France il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en cause la règle
applicable à tous les demandeurs d'asile
dont on sait pertinemment qu'une part
majoritaire n'obtiendra pas le statut de
réfugié en revanche laisser travailler
un individu originaire d'un pays pour
lequel les ressortissants obtiennent
l'asile dans 90 % des cas c'est
pragmatique cela favorisera son
intégration et nous y sommes favorables
je conclurai enfin en prenant une
analyse de notre collègue mon cher
Jean-Louis bourlange ce dernier
considère qu'il règne en France
actuellement un climat de peur et
d'insécurité dû en grande partie à une
perte de confiance dans nos institutions
ce texte à l'ône de nouvelles procédures
administrative essaie de remédier à ce
constat il vient compléter d'autres
mesures déjà prises en y mettant encore
plus d'exigences il correspond à une
attente de nos concitoyens une attente
de fermeté et d'efficacité puisque le
sondage paru hier montre que les 3/4 de
l'opinion publique soutiennent le
présent projet de loi enfin à celles et
ceux qui veulent fermer les frontières
de notre pays je souhaite juste rappeler
que la France s'est construite de tout
temps grâce à l'arrivée d'étrangers
venant de multiples pays et à qui elle
doit une grande partie de sa richesse et
de son rayonnement je vous
remercie merci Madame madame Floren la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Guy
bénaroche pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame messieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues avant d'entrer dans le
détail important de ce projet de loi
pour contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration il est bon de
rappeler qu'il est le 30e texte
effectivement monsieur le ministre sur
la question de l'immigration depuis les
années 80 à la lecture on peut être
heurté par son déséquilibre provoqué
tant par la parti sécuritaire du texte
gouvernemental initial que par la
version de la commission des Lois du
Sénat qui reste sans voix sur les 3 et 4
au cœur de l'intégration prévue tout en
renforçant ces aspects punitifs je sais
que nous ne définissons pas
l'immigration ni ne la caractérisons pas
tous de la même façon l'immigration est
un phénomène normal historique récurrent
point commun de l'histoire des
civilisations qui a participé et qui
participera à l'évolution de notre
culture et à la construction de notre
pays c'est un phénomène démographique
complexe tributaire de contingences
géopolitiques comme les guerres les
famine et même conséc maintenant du
changement climatique mais d'autres
fables voient de plus en plus le jour
dans la réalité aucun mur physique ou
administratif n'a pu empêcher
durablement l'être humain d'aller voir
ailleurs quand cela est lié à sa survie
tant d'épisodes tragiques nous le
rappelle en Méditerranée en Manche et
ailleurs un phénomène qui conduira
encore plus de mouvements dans les
années à venir au sein et entre les pays
et les continents l'appréhension du
phénomène migratoire ne peut pas se
passenser qu'à l'OND d'une vision
sécuritaire sauf à assimiler l'étranger
à une menace ce que nous refusons le
ministère de l'Intérieur ne doit pas
être l'unique maître d'œuvre de la
politique migratoire de notre pays il
est urgent de nous pencher sur la
création d'un ministère dédié à la
politique d'immigration d'accueil et
d'intégration comme notre groupe
notamment au travers de mon collègue
Thomas DASU a déjà pu
l'exprimer l'équilibre cherché par cette
loi est loin de la promesse
présidentielle de de 2019 je crois au
vrai en même temps sur la politique
migratoire aussi alors quelle est
l'histoire présentée aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement et réécrite par la
commission des Lois du Sénat ne soyons
pas dupes et analysons l'intérêt
politicien devenu le fondement de ce
texte dont le parcours jusqu'à ce jour
est plus qu'ératique certes vous
déclarez monsieur le ministre il y a
quelques jours dans un journal du
dimanche l'enjeu est trop important pour
la nation pour faire de la politique
politicienne pourtant tout dans la
gestion de ce texte n'est que le reflet
d'un calcul politicien sinon comment
expliquer son retrait de la séance
publique en mars dernier car il
n'existait pas de majorité pour voter à
tel texte comment expliquer les annonces
présidentielles parlant en mars du fait
qu'il y aura bien une loi immigration il
y en aura même sans doute plusieurs de
textes qui arriveront dans les
prochaines semaines comment accorder
cela avec la déclaration de la première
ministre en avril ce n'est pas le moment
de lancer un débat sur un sujet qui
pourrait diviser le pays aait comme seul
Bousson l'efficacité aujourd'hui vous
pensez réellement que le climat est plus
apaisé qu'en
avril la politisation trossière de la
question migratoire est un piège qui ne
doit profiter à personne et qui va
malheureusement profiter à certains
comment expliquer sinon que l'on soit
passé d'un texte je cite gentil avec les
gentils méchant avec les méchants
c'était la morale de la fable au texte
je cite le plus ferme avec les mesures
les plus dures depuis ces 30 dernières
années la France ne peut pas accueillir
tout le monde si elle veut accueillir
bien disait le président 2019
mieux accueillir est-ce procéder dans le
budget une baisse des crédits octroyé
pour la loocation des demandeurs d'asile
de plus d'un tiers 36 % comme l'an
dernier quel décalage entre la réalité
et le récit notre pays ne peut pas
mettre les gens dans des situations
irrégulières vis-à-vis de la loi du fait
de la complexité croissante de
l'inflation législative nationale ou
européenne comment ne pas voir que ce
texte n'apporte rien au phénomène
inascusable de précarisation des
étrangers venonsant à l'intégration par
le travail c'était l'un des deux piliers
mis en avant par les ministres d'armanin
et du S l'accès au travail est la clé de
l'intégration des adultes arrivant sur
notre sol je sais que c'est une
conviction partagé au vu du traitement
des Ukrainiens lors de leur arrivée la
crise ukrainienne a montré que l'Europe
et que notre pays pouvait accueillir
bien accueillir et rapidement accueillir
lorsque la volonté politique y est le
dérogatoire ukrainien qui a fait ses
preuves ne devrait-il pas tendre à
devenir la règle la question de la
régularisation la jambe gauche bien
maigrichante du texte celle contenue en
parti de dans l'article 3 est essentiel
permettez-moi de rappeler l'objectif
annoncé régulariser les travailleurs
sans papier pour faciliter leur
intégration pour leur éviter d'être à la
mercie des raisons mafieux et pour
permettre à de nombreuses branches de
notre économie de fonctionner
normalement comme beaucoup d'employeurs
le demandent aujourd'hui que nous
dites-vous monsieur le ministre sans le
ministre du Travail qu'en fait vous
allez passer un accord avec la droite
pour faire en sorte que cet article 3 ne
permett de régulariser que le moins de
mes possible sans satisfaire aucun des
objectifs que vous aviez vous-même
annoncés comment ne pas vouloir
permettre à des personnes qui
travaillent qui veulent s'intégrer de
s'extirper de la peur permanente du
contrôle de l'éloignement et d'un nouvel
exode personne ne peut être complètement
intégré même après des années avec cette
craite permanente intégré par le travail
c'est aussi régularisé par le travail au
CTF accru multiplication descin et en
même temps plus de contraite pour
renouveler les demandes pour les
étudiants par exemple pour les prises de
rendez-vous en préfecture pour
l'obtention des titre on sait déjà à
quel point la situation et les délis
d'obtention sera insupportable nous
étions prêts à féliciter le gouvernement
pour en fait agir sur la rétention des
mineurs dans les cras mais la limitation
des mineurs à l'âge de 16 ans est une
farce qui nous paraît peu drôle vous
mettez en place les défaillances du
système de la CNDA manque de moyens de
personnel et en même temps vous appuyez
sur ces délais rendu trôant pour
justifier une réflexion au sujet des
modifications des règles de droit pour
limiter les recours et généraliser le
juge unique les assesseurs de la
formation collégiale ne sont pas
forcément des magistrats ne plus faire
appel à la collégialité notamment aux
membres désignés par le Haut Commissaire
des Nations Unies pour les réfugiés
n'accélérera pas les procédures oui il y
a une embouisation d' système ma calibré
mais la seule réponse est un calibrage
adapté avec un hbre de locaux et de
personnel adéquate nous groupes
écologistes et solidarité sommes
clairement en faveur d'une meilleure
célérité des procédures mais jamais au
dépend des fondamentaux de la justice
des droits des personnes des conditions
travail des agents de service public je
pense aujourd'hui aussi à l'enterrement
définitif de la promesse d'Orléan de
2017 qui avait vu le président déclarer
qu'aucun demandeur d'asile ne dormirait
dehors rien de ce qui nous a été
présenté ne s'attelle à ce sujet
pourtant essentiel et comment ne pas
dire comme l'ont souligné des milliers
de médecins acteurs de la santé et du
social que la fait de laame est une
aberration quelle est cette légende de
soi-disant appel d'air que tous les
chiffres et tous les témoignages
démentent monsieur le ministre messieurs
les rapporteurs nous devons veiller à
une inconditionnalité de la dignité dans
l'accueil à juste titre c'est vraiment
notre honneur je regrette que cet
honneur soit variable entre l'Aquarius
et l'océan de Viking l'acceptabilité des
refus doit s'ancrer dans le respect des
procédures et des personnes et une prise
en charge digne de l'accueil jusqu'au
traitement des demandes chers collègues
n'y voyez ni naïveté ni idéalisme
utopique mais au contraire entendez le
besoin d'accueillir humainement de mieux
respecter la dignité de Chun ce projet
de loi ne le permet pas à nous la
responsabilité de le changer dans les
jours qui viennent merci merci Monsieur
bénaroche la parole est désormais à
Monsieur Yan brossa pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
kaki monsieur le Président Monsieur le
le ministre ce ce projet de loi tel
qu'il ressort en tout cas de sa
réécriture par la commission des Lois du
Sénat par au fond d'un principe l'idée
que l'étranger serait d'abord une menace
dont il faudrait se prémunir un péril
dont il faudrait se protéger un danger
qu'il nous reviendrait d'écarter je veux
le dire d'emblé pour résumer l'état
d'esprit de notre groupe nous ne
partageons pas cette vision des choses
et toutes les mesures qui en découle
qu'un pays bien sûr définisse des règles
en matière d'immigration c'est
parfaitement naturel et parfaitement
légitime qu'il veille à leur respect
c'est légitime également en revanche que
la politique d'immigration se consacre
quasi exclusivement à faire des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre sol des
suspects s'en est une autre et nous n'y
adhérrons jamais il suffit d'ailleurs
pour démentir cette vision des choses de
regarder la société en face de regarder
en face la grande masse des étrangers
qui vivent sur notre sol qu'ils aident
des papiers ou pas ceux dont on ne parle
finalement jamais ceux qui travaillent
en silence ceux qui bien souvent
prennent le premier métro pour que les
cadres de la défense puissent travailler
dans des bureaux propres de tout cela
personne ne parle jamais ils sont
pourtant là sous nos yeux dans les
cuisines des restaurants alentour dans
les chantiers où se préparent les Jeux
Olympiques dans les épades où
travaillent les auxiliaires de vie dans
les hôpitaux où travaillent tant de
médecins étrangers dans dans nos champs
où travaillent tant d'ouvriers agricoles
dans nos universités où travaillent tant
de chercheurs étrangers ne pas voir
cette réalité ne pas voir la réalité de
la grande masse des étrangers qui vivent
sur notre sol c'est faire le choix du
déni c'est refuser de voir que ces
femmes que ces hommes travaillent ici
produisent des richesses ici participent
du rayonnement de notre pays respecte
les lois les principes et les valeurs de
la
République ces hommes ces femmes-là ceux
dont je parle à l'instant ceux qui
représentent la grande masse des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre
territoire sont assurément beaucoup plus
patriotes et beaucoup plus loyaux à la
France que tous ces émigrés fiscaux qui
continuent à bénéficier d'un laxisme
coupable vous l'avez compris notre
vision des choses est à mil000 lieu de
celle que défend la majorité sénatorial
et le gouvernement nous sommes à la fois
en désaccord avec votre constat de
départ et en des accord par conséquent
avec toutes les mesures qui en découlent
en effet toutes les mesures qui ont été
voté en commission des lois vise en
réalité à aggraver le projet initial
présenté par le gouvernement c'est la
limitation du droit du sol c'est la
limitation du regroupement familial ce
qui est d'ailleurs totalement
contradictoire avec l'objectif
d'intégration car il va bien falloir
m'expliquer comment un étranger qui
vient en France peut s'intégrer dès lors
qu'il n'a pas la possibilité de vivre en
en famille et c'est par ailleurs la
remise en cause de l'aide médicale
d'État au fond partant de l'idée que
l'immigré est une menace vous déployez
une stratégie une stratégie qui consiste
à penser que vous réduirez les flux
migratoir en dégradant les conditions
d'accueil de ceux qui viennent chercher
refuse chez nous c'est totalement faux
d'abord parce que depuis des années
maintenant les conditions d'accueil de
ceux qui viennent chez nous ont déjà été
considér ement dégradé et ça n'a en
aucun cas conduit à ce que les flux se
tarissent ensuite parce que le faible
taux de recours de toute une série
d'aides dont pourrait bénéficier les
immigrés qui viennent sur notre
territoire prouve bien que les gens ne
viennent pas pour des aides comment
expliquer autrement que sur l'aide
médicale d'État on est un taux de
recours d'à peine 50 % autrement dit que
50 % de ceux qui auraient droit à l'aide
médicale d'État n'y ont pas recours
comment expliquer que sur le RSA 70 %
des étrangers en situation régulière
évidemment sinon il n'y aurait pas droit
hors Union Européenne qui pourrait y
avoir droit n'y ont pas recours c'est
bien la preuve que ceux qui viennent
chez nous ne viennent pas pour
bénéficier d'aide et c'est par ailleurs
se tromper fondamentalement parce que ce
qui provoque la migration ça n'est pas
la situation de la personne dans son
pays d'accueil ça n'est pas
l'attractivité du pays d'accueil c'est
la situation du pays de départ et donc
agir sur les flux c'est agir
sur la situation du pays de départ et
non pas dégrader les conditions
d'accueil sur notre sol à partir de là
au fond deux possibilités se présentent
à nous soit nous restons dans le déniis
nous continuons à vendre le mirage d'une
immigration zéro ou d'une immigration
quasi réduite à néant et à ce moment-là
nous laisserons le chaos s'organiser
soit nous regardons la réalité des
migrations en face et nous nous
organisons à dessin nous organisons
l'accueil digne et nous organisons
l'intégration l'intégration par l'école
l'intégration par la langue
l'intégration par le travail et c'est
d'ailleurs précisément parce que cette
organisation fait défaut que nous en
sommes là aujourd'hui et c'est
précisément cela qui nourrit le discours
sur le chaos migratoire c'est l'absence
de voie légale d'immigration qui crée un
marché pour les passeurs c'est l'absence
d'hébergement digne qui crée un marché
pour les marchands de sommeil et
d'ailleurs nous proposons un amendement
qui vise à permettre aux victimes des
marchands de sommeil qui portent plainte
de bénéficier d'un titre de séjour
provisoire ce qui permettrait
précisément de les protéger c'est
l'absence de régularisation massive par
le travail qui crée les conditions pour
que des patrons voyou puissent profiter
de la misère autrement dit le drame ce
n'est pas l'immigration c'est
l'exploitation qui en est faite par un
certain nombre de gens qui profitent de
la misère humaine et quand même cela a
été dit tout à l'heure mais le fait que
en commission des lois l'article 8 qui
permet de pénaliser les employeurs qui
embauchent des Spiers c'est quand même
une question qui devrait tous nous
interpeller parce que dans une relation
d'exploitation qui est coupable c'est
l'exploiteur ou c'est celui qui est
exploité et donc je le dis ici la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier est ce qui nous permettrait de
sortir de l'hypocrisie dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui vous l'aurez
compris la vision que nous défendons est
aux antipodes de celle du texte qui est
ressorti de la commission des lois et je
voudrais que nous soyons attentifs au
fait que lorsque nous parlons deeux
lorsque nous parlons de ces étrangers
qui vivent sur notre sol lorsque nous
mettons en place des politiques qui les
concernent nous parlons d'abord de nous
et de ce que nous voulons faire de notre
pays et des valeurs que nous voulons
défendre dans notre
pays merci merci monsieur Bross la
parole est maintenant à Marie scarer
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen madame
la Présidente
car monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madamees et monsieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
ces dernières décennies notre hémicycle
a eu plutôt l'habitude légitime de se
plaindre du millefeuille administratif à
travers la prolifération des strates d'
adistration locale le menu de cette
semaine ne s'en éloigne finalement pas
tellement puisque nous allons nous
pencher sur un autre millefeuille mais
celui-ci change de saveur il est
législatif depuis le début des années 80
notre Parlement a déjà voté presque 33
lois sur l'immigration soit environ une
tous les 17 mois une fois que nous avons
ces chiffres à l'esprit on s'interroge
forcément sur la nécessité d'un nouveau
texte alors même que nous n'avons pas
encore tiré tous les bilans de la loi
colon qui nourrissait pourtant les amb
Miss assez similaire à celle du projet
que nous examinons mais il est vrai que
le monde change et qu'il faut s'adapter
mais essayons d'en tirer les de tirer
les leçons des expériences précédentes
toutefois en découvrant le texte dans sa
version initiale nous avons d'abord été
plutôt surpris il comprenait des mesures
pour lesquelles nous étions favorables
et celles qui nous contrariait le plus
restait malgré tout mesuré côté positif
il avait évidemment les articles 3 et 4
nous sommes absolument favorables à ce
que les travailleurs igr sortte d'une
situation de précarité difficile marqué
par des emplois instables une faible
rémunération et l'absence de tout
dispositif de protection sociale il n'y
a pas de doute que l'intégration par le
travail soit efficace et valorisante et
qui n'a pas au sein de cet hémicycle
reçu sur son département l'appel d'un
chef d'entreprise devant se séparer de
son employé pour pour non régularisation
de papier côté négatif je pense bien sûr
avec un exemple de la l'exemple de la
réforme du contentieux des étrangers
certes nos administrations et
juridictions font face à de réelles
difficultés de l'engorgement de la
complexité juridique pour autant ces
difficultés juridiques et le manque de
moyens humains ne saurait être compensé
par des renoncement à nos principes
fondamentaux notamment la collégialité
des juridictions et la publicité des
débats il s'agit ici de principes que
nous défendons systématiquement à chaque
réforme contentieuse et institutionnelle
il aurait peut-être été plus judicieux
de former le fond du droit en le
simplifiant et en le clarifiant les
résultats d'une telle démarche sur la
célérité et l'efficacité de la justice
serit peut-être plus probant nous y
reviendrons lors de l'examen des
articles et des amendements toujours
est-il que dans sa première mouture le
texte aurait pu convenir à notre groupe
sous réserve de quelques aménagements
mais sans le modifier sans en profondeur
puis est venu l'examen par notre
commission des lois et là ce projet de
loi sur l'immigration a pris une
tournure radicale pour ne pas dire même
parfois brutal je m'attarderai seulement
sur quelques exemples car nous aurons le
temps de détailler nos nos positions
durant cette semaine d'examen d'abord
l'article 1er I qui propose de
substituer à l'aide médicale d'État une
aide médicale d'urgence cette mesure est
symptomatique d'un état d'esprit cet
état d'esprit qui a donné au projet de
loi une tournure éloignant tout espoir
de consensus car avec cet article ajouté
par notre commission nous retrouvons un
parti prix sur l'immigration car
factuellement économiquement et
sanitairement rien ne le
justifie certains décrivent ce
dispositif comme engendrant des effets
d'appel d'air et pourtant d'une part
toutes les personnes éligibles à l'AME
n'en bénéficient pas réellement et cela
même lorsqu'elle déclare souffrir de
maladies nécessitant des soins d'autre
part moins de 10 % des étrangers en
situation irrégulière évoquent la santé
comme un motif devenu en France j'ai du
mal à y voir un usage abusif
économiquement et sanitairement ensuite
nous sortons d'une pandémie qui a
rappelé les impératifs les plus
fondamentaux en matière de santé
publique que se passera-t-il lorsque
notre pays nous ne soignerons dans notre
pays nous ne soignerons plus une partie
de la population pour défaut de titre de
séjour quelle réaction auront les
médecin nous le savons tous très bien
cette suppression idéologique pourrait
avoir de graves conséquences pour le
système de santé français et constitue
un nonsens économique puisque les
pathologies hospitalières prises en
charge tardivement sont particulièrement
coûteuse autre dispositif préoccupant
ajouté par le Sénat les articles de bis
et de terr qui viennent marquer un recul
très net du droit du sol mais surtout
qui place des mineurs donc des enfants
et des adolescents desquels nous
exigerons une manifestation de volonté
et pour le dire simplement un casier
judiciaire vierge alors que notre
assemblée s'attache le plus souvent à
défendre le droit des enfants et de la
jeunesse j'ai du mal à comprendre que ce
sujet soit encore débattu s'agissant de
la manifestation de volonté je veux bien
y voir un intérêt symbolique mais en
pratique ce ne sera qu'une démarche
administrative de plus sans efficacité
concrète ensuite concernant les mineurs
condamnés à une peine de 6 mois ces
jeunes n'auront donc plus de droit à
l'erreur à l'erreur alors même que notre
Parlement peine par exemple à adopter ce
type de mesure pour les élus et je ne
suis pas sûre d'être à l'aise avec cette
exigence asymétrique de moralisation il
reste toujours en suspend les articles 3
et 4 comme une sorte de dernier espoir
pour que le texte puisse encore être
défendu puisque nos rapporteurs n'ont
pas su n'ont pas trouvé un accord
j'espère que notre hémicycle sera
favorable euh à ces deux articles qui
nous semblent fondamentaux pour que
notre pays parvienne à plus d'apaisement
et de sérénité face à la question de
l'immigration dernier point sur lesquels
nous ne pouvons pas faire l'impasse la
question des OQTF question difficile car
souvent prise de populisme nous sommes
forcément saisis par lesé carart qui
existent entre d'un côté le nombre d'qtf
prononcé et de l'autre celles qui sont
finalement exécuté il y a d'autant plus
un problème que chacun a déjà rencontré
dans son département le cas d'une
personne parfaitement intégrée et
pourtant menacée d'expulsion il est rare
que ces personnes soient concernées par
les dispositions des articles 9 et 10 du
projet de
loi autrement dit il faut trouver
l'équilibre pour cesser de prononcer des
OQTF à l'encontre des personnes
intégrées et appliquer fermement celle
qui vise des personnes risquant
d'atteindre à la sûreté de notre nation
cela étant nous admettons que cette
équation est difficile à résoudre notre
seule certitude sur le sujet est qu'il
ne passe il ne sera pas réglé si chacun
campe sur ses
postures impossible donc pour en
conclusion je dirais qu'il est
impossible aujourd'hui en l'état de dire
la position du RDSE à l'issue de du vote
de l'examen de ce texte il faudront il
faudra donc attendre l'examen des
amendements pour nous positionner
toutefois si le texte n'était pas
modifié lors de la séance publique peu
voir aucun d'entre nous ne le
soutiendront je vous
remercie merci Madame carer la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Olivier bis
pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et
indépendants monsieur le président
madame et monsieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madamees et monsieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues chacune et chacun le
sait bien les flux migratoires se sont
accélérés ces dernières années à
l'échelle mondiale instabilité politique
évolution démographique inégalité de
toutes sortes et changement climatiqu
viennent provoquer une mobilité
croissante des populations ainsi selon
l'OCDE l'immigration dans les pays
riches a atteint des niveaux records en
2022 cette progression rapide trouve
bien bien évidemment sa traduction en
Europe et dans notre pays en 2022 320000
autorisations de séjour ont été délivré
par la France alors que dans le même
temps 131 demandes d'asile y ont été
enregistrées bien évidemment bien
évidemment les entrées clandestines
viennent s'ajouter à à ces chiffres déjà
considérables à l'évidence cette
trajectoire n'est pas soutenable dans la
durée pour notre cohésion nationale elle
ne correspond pas à la capacité
d'accueil de notre pays encore moins à
sa capacité d'intégration l'échelle
européenne est bien sûr pertinente pour
régler les pour réguler les phénomènes
migratoires et nous nous réjouissons de
l'élon donné l'année dernière par la
présidence française pour aboutir à
l'adoption prochaine du pacte européen
sur la migration et l'asile la dimension
européenne du sujet ne nous empêche
cependant pas de muscler notre droit
interne car il y a nécessité de mieux
soutier juridiquement pour faire face à
cette évolution de la situation l'état
de notre droit ne nous permet pas
aujourd'hui d'agir assez assez
efficacement pour réduire les flux
migratoires mieux protéger nos
concitoyens des délinquants étrangers et
affirmer avec force notre attachement au
principes et valeurs de la République la
loi du 10 septembre 2018 avait déjà fixé
le cap il s'agit maintenant d'accélérer
accélérer à la fois sur les moyens
juridiques donnés à l'état pour mener
une politique plus ferme mais aussi
parallèlement sur les moyens financiers
qui lui sont confiés pour atteindre cet
objectif à cet égard la cohérence entre
la volonté politique du gouvernement et
les moyens qu'il a demandé et obtenus
avec l'adoption de la l'opmie doit être
souligné un seul exemple pour améliorer
l'exécution des décisions l'éloignement
l'objectif de 3000 places de rétention
administrative d'ici 2027 est d'ors et
déjà programmé et financé la nécessité
d'une évolution plus rigoureuse de notre
droit est une conviction largement
partagée sur la méthode je me réjouis de
constater à quel point ce projet de loi
a été enrichi par les travaux de la
commission des lois et la reprise par le
gouvernement de la quasi-ttalité des
propositions faites il s'agit d'un bel
exemple d'un processus de coconstruction
qui devrait nous permettre d'avancer et
je tiens ici à saluer tout
particulièrement la volonté de dialogue
et d'échange du ministre
d'intérieur ne pas adopter ce projet
reviendrait Infiné à se satisfaire de
l'état du droit actuel ce serait prendre
une lourde responsabilité car notre pays
a besoin de renforcer les exigences
concernant l'intégration en demandant au
demand d'une carte de séjour
pluréannuelle la connaissance d'un
niveau minimum de français mais aussi un
engagement à respecter les principes de
la République pour protéger nos
concitoyens la menace grave pour l'ordre
public doit devenir un motif de non
renouvellement ou de retrait de la carte
de résident dans le même sens le projet
de loi vient faciliter l'éloignement des
étrangers qui représente une menace
grave pour l'ordre public il s'agit
aussi de mettre à l'honneur la valeur
travail en faisant de l'activité
économique un facteur d'intégration
mieux reconnu au moment même où nombre
de nos entreprises souffrent de ne pas
trouver la main d'œuvre qui leur est
nécessaire on a pu un temps entendre un
peu tout et n'importe quoi sur ce
désormais célèbre article 3 alors même
qu'il ne s'agit que d'un dispositif
expérimental limité dans le temps
permettant de ne délivrer qu'un titre
temporaire d'un an renouvelable sous
conditions à des personnes se trouvant
déjà sur le territoire depuis au moins 3
ans et dont le pays a besoin de
l'activité cela ne mérite à l' pas tous
les excès entendus par ailleurs
représentant l'Orne territoire rural qui
comme beaucoup d'autres territoires
ruraux représentent un désert médical je
me réjouis des mesures facilitant la
situation au regard de leur droit au
séjour des médecins diplômés à
l'étranger enfin la simplification du
contentieux des étrangers est très
attendu en ayant comme objectif
d'accélérer les procédures tout en
conservant l'effectivité du droit au
recours vous l'aurez compris sans
surprise le groupe rdpays soutiendra la
volonté du gouvernement de muscler
notutre droit en faisant preuve de
pragmatisme et d'humanité je vous
remerci merci merci Monsieur wi à la
demande de Monsieur le Ministre nous
interrompons pendant 5 minutes la
séance
ministre là nous allons donc reprendre
la séance avec Madame Corine
naraassiguin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain à vous madame
pour 9
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues
contrairement à ce ce que certains
disent nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
confrontés à une vague d'immigration les
composants de ce mouvement migratoire
sont multiples elles sont en premier
lieu le résultat du regroupement
familial cette pratique demeure
marginale et doit être préservée ces
mouvements migratoires comptent aussi
des étudiants des demandeurs d'asile
dont le nombre a certes un peu augmenté
mais dans des proportions qui n'ont rien
de comparable à ce que l'on constate
chez nos voisins le sujet de
l'immigration ne devrait donc pas
inquiéter la population française et
pourtant pourquoi fait-il débat parce
qu'il est source à la fois de confusion
de malentendu d'une forme d'inquiétude
ou comme le diraient certains auteurs
d'insécurité culturelle mais les racines
d'un tel sentiment résident dans la
question de l'intégration pas dans le
fait migratoire nous ne devons pas
mentir à nos concitoyens
l'immigration n'est pas quelque chose
dont nous pourrions nous départir de sur
croix l'immigration se révèle une chance
d'un point de vue économique culturel
social mais à condition de savoir la
prendre en charge quand on sait les
intégrer les former les femmes et les
hommes renouvellent notre société puis
donneent une impulsion nouvelle des
élans d'éventivité d'innovation les
démocraties qui réussissent intégration
bénéficient d'une croissance supérieure
à la nôtre mais la question de
l'intégration reste un problème en
France nous ne parvenons plus à nous
départir d'une défiance à l'égard des
migrants monsieur le ministre ces
premiers mots de mon propos sont ceux
d'Emmanuel Macron alors candidat à
l'élection présidentielle en février
2017 mais alors que s'est-il passé
depuis que s'est-il passé monsieur le
ministre pour que vous nous présentiez
le 29e projet de loi sur l'immigration
depuis les années 80 en faisant croire à
nos concitoyens qu'il résoudra enfin
tout le problème que s'est-il passé pour
que vous assumiez d'être condamné par la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
aussi régulièrement que s'est-il passé
pour que vous nous présentiez le texte
le plus dur et le plus ferme sur
l'immigration depuis les 30 dernières
années comme vous le
proclamez que s'est-il passé pour que le
Président de la République renie ses
positions intérieures sur la question
migratoire la France d'aujourd'hui est
l'héritière d'une histoire complexe
qu'elle doit apprendre à assumer
elle est de fait un pays d'immigration
et une terre d'accueil l'immigration est
une réalité structurelle que nous devons
embrasser nous socialistes considérons
qu'une immigration réussie passe par
l'intégration et cette intégration a
trois composantes essentielles le
travail l'apprentissage de la langue
ainsi que laamxité à l'école et dans le
logement alors quand je lis le titre de
votre projet de loi et que je vois
améliorer l'intégration je dis pourquoi
pas l'apprentissage de la langue tout
d'abord monsieur le ministre vous vous V
c'est partout que ce projet de loi
facilitera l'apprentissage de la langue
du français on y regarde de plus près
c'est faux la vérité est que vous
utilisez la maîtrise de la langue
française comme un obstacle à l'entrée
et à l'installation durable au lieu de
vous inquiéter des moyens de son
apprentissage autre volet essentiel pour
s'intégrer le travail quoi de mieux pour
le que le travail pour s'intégrer un
travail digne a anticipateur et porteur
de sens
il y a 1 an quand vous souhaitiez être
gentil avec les gentils au côté de
Monsieur dus sopt qui a d'ailleurs
disparu des radars depuis c'était la
mesure phare de votre texte le travail
vous le savez nous soutenons cet article
3 qui vise à régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension c'est une mesure très
insuffisante mais c'est un premier pas
dans la bonne direction les Français ne
sont pas dupes et voi bien que les
secteurs de la restauration l'hôtellerie
le BTP l'aide aux personnes la propreté
ou encore le numérique fonctionne grâce
à de nombreux travailleurs sans papier
ils sont les travailleurs de l'ombre qui
font tourner notre pays ils étaient
celles et ceux qui sortaient chaque jour
en risquant leur vie pendant la covid-19
ils sont ceux nous vous en déplaise
chers collègues qui é plusevx légumes et
font la plonge au restaurant du
Séna mais au-delà de cette vision très
utilitariste de l'article 3 nous sommes
pour la régularisation de l'ensemble des
travailleurs sans papier sur le territ
teritoire français il s'agit d'arrêter
avec une forme d'hypocrisie et de leur
permettre de vivre légalement sur les
territoires sans cette peur au ventre et
le risque d'être contrôlé à tout moment
pour être renvoyé dans leur pays il
contribuent à la vie économique sociale
et culturelle de notre pays ils doivent
pouvoir y vivre en toute éégalité nous
proposerons donc que l'ensemble des
travailleurs puisse être régularisé
après 6 mois de CDI CDD ou intérim nous
souhaitons également que cette mesure
s'applique aux travailleurs des plformme
qui sont des milliers à participer à
notre économie nous soutiendrons
également la possibilité de travailler
dès le dépôt de la demande
d'asile nous soutenons votre mesure mais
sans illusion car nous avons bien
compris que vous êtes en négociation
privilégiée avec la droite extrême
représenté dans cet hémicycle par
Monsieur retaillot qui veut supprimer
cet article 3 Le seul élément relatif à
l'intégration dans votre texte
concernant le deuxème volet mieux
contrôler l'immigration il s ag en
réalité de la partie la plus importante
de votre texte et je le dis sans détour
nous socialistes nous pensons qu'une
organisation des politiques migratoires
est nécessaire une organisation fidèle
aux valeurs de la République pour mieux
accueillir et mieux intégrer votre
projet de loi c'est au contraire ajouter
du désordre désordre suite au dramatique
attentat d'aras vous instrumentalisez la
crainte du terrorisme islamiste pour
multiplier les almagalmes faire le lien
entre immigration insécurité et
terrorisme et justifier le durcissement
de votre texte mais cela sans véritable
vision de l'immigration et sans même
aucune notion d'efficacité la sûreté de
l'État et la sécurité de nos
concitoyenes et nos concitoyens méritent
mieux que la démagogie elles exigent un
discours de vérité parce que nous sommes
lucides sur la réalité des menaces
sécuritaires nous sommes prêts à aller
au bout du débat et de votre bilan en
matière de contrôle de l'immigration à
chaque fois que vous essaierez d'emb
d'embrouiller les Françaises et les
Français nous serons là pour rappeler
les faits les régimes de l'expulsion et
de l'éloignement que vous confondez au
mépris des mises en garde du Conseil
d'État n'ont pas besoin d'être modifiés
l'enjeu c'est la bonne application du
droit existant plutôt que de multiplier
les octtf mettez des moyens au
préfecture et à l'administration pour le
suivi des individus véritablement
dangereux cessez vos effets de manange
et agissez
efficacement nous nous opposerons
également à la fin de la collégialité au
sein de la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile où l'oralité et l'intime
conviction tiennent une place des cisive
une décision de la CNDA peut parfois
renvoyer des personnes à la mort il est
essentiel que cette décision ne soit pas
individuelle pour être la plus juste
possible enfin nous combattrons les
mesures noséabondes de la droite dans
cet hémicycle qui n'a plus de
républicaine que le nom ces mesures que
vous faites vôre comme vous le dites si
bien monsieur le ministre suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État restriction du
regroupement familial remise en cause du
droit du sol sur ce dernier point nous
sommes choqués du silence du
gouvernement le droit du sol est une
composante fondamentale du droit de la
nationalité et de l'intégration
républicaine réveillez-vous supprimer
les articles de bis et de
terre monsieur le ministre vous vouliez
une loi immigration qui porte votre nom
finalement
sétapoprié ce projet de loi est une
opération de communication qui au mieux
ne servira à rien ou à pas grand-chose
au pire sera néfaste avec ce texte vous
voulez faire passer l'agitation pour de
l'action l'effet d'annonce pour de
l'efficacité la fanfaonade pour
l'autorité vous ne vous souciez plus des
droits fondamentaux de notre
constitution de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme face à sa dérive
illibérale nous serons les garants de
notre État de droit nous serons celles
et ceux qui ne mentent pas au français
pour remettre de l'ordre dans notre
République il faut une immigration
organisée un accueil organisé une
intégration organisée et penser une
politique claire applicable et appliquée
votre projet de loi c'est M nuance des
politiques d'exclusion nous serons de
celles et ceux qui considèrent que
l'immigration est une chance pour notre
pays nous serons de celles et ceux qui
pensent l'intégration plutôt que
l'exclusion nous serons de celles et
ceux qui rappelleront que ces personnes
sont avant tout des êtres humains des
hommes des femmes et des
enfants merci madame la sénatrice la
parole est à monsieur le président Bruno
retaillot pour le groupe les
républicains
pour 10
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les désordres migratoires
actuels sont sans doute que les
prémisses de desésordres plus violents
de ceousse théléurique beaucoup beaucoup
plus violentes qui sont à venir avec le
dérèglement climatique je l'ai entendu
tout à l'heure avec les règlement
géopolitique et et avec aussi les
déséquilibres démographiques et
d'ailleurs dans le monde occidental
beaucoup beaucoup de gouvernement et de
droite et de gauche durcissent
considérablement leur législation
nationale le dernier en dat ça a été
souligné c'est l'Allemagne c'est
Monsieur Scholz qui a présenté un projet
de loi il a d'ailleurs eu une
déclaration fracassante que je cite au
motamoot en indiquant que il fallait
expulser à grande échelle les gens qui
n'ont pas le droit de rester en
Allemagne et Joe Biden vient de
poursuivre l'œuvre si j'ose dire de
Monsieur Trump puisque il a décidé la
continuation du mur sur la frontière
mexicaine je rappelle simplement que
Monsieur Biden est démocrate et que
Monsieur Olaf Scholz est socialdémocrate
dans tous ces pays et dans tous les pays
d'Occident en réalité la demande de
fermeté elle vient des classes
populaires elle ne vient pas des classes
aisées qui ont les moyens de se projéger
des conséquences du désordre migratoire
en mettant leurs enfants dans les bonnes
écoles et en habitant les beaux
quartiers la réalité elle est là
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
semaines vous aviez déclaré dans un
journal du dimanche que sur
l'immigration vous n'aviez aucun tableou
je ne demande qu'à vous croire sur
parole mais j'ai quelques doutes
pourquoi autant d'atterermoimement
pourquoi un accouchement aussi difficile
avec un texte tant de fois promis et un
texte tant de fois remis je pense au
contraire que pour votre majorité pour
votre majorité l'immigration reste un
tabou un tabou
d'abord sur le plan politique c'est le
en même temps qui débouche sur un double
jeu un tabou surtout sur le plan
numérique la question du nombre qui est
fondamentale et un tabou sur le plan du
droit la question du droit qui est aussi
absolument essentiel d'abord le premier
tabout c'est la question du du nombre
tout nous y ramène tout nous y ramène
absolument parce que l'échec de
l'intégration vient du fait que on peut
intégrer des petits nombres des
individus mais comment intégrer des
populations qui souvent sont peu
désireuses d'adhérer à nos principes
républicain et à nos modes de vie qui
peut ici dire de façon sérieuse qu'il
n'y a pas de lien entre tous ces échecs
entre tous ces échecs et l'insécurité
qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre tous ces
échecs sur l'intégration et la
multiplication des territoires perdus de
la République qu'elle soit légale ou
illégale
le problème de l'immigration but sur la
loi des grand nombres c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas cet
article 3 qui est devenu certes un peu
totéique mais je je voudrais y revenir
quelques instants d'abord parce que on
ne peut pas à la fois prétendre dans un
texte lutter contre l'immigration
illégale et ouvrir une brèche à
l'immigration illégale la fraude ne peut
pas être une voie de régularisation
parce que alors là on ouvre encore une
fois une fac ité qui va créer un appel
d'air la deuxème la deuxème raison la
deuxème raison c'est que c'est une
formidable capitulation que d'aller
chercher une main d'œuvre bon marché
quand en France il nous faut encore
mobiliser une réserve extraordinaire de
travail qu'on ne mobilise pas au momentù
je vous parle il y a plus de 560000
étrangers qui eux sont en situation
régulière et qui sont au chômage au
moment où je vous parle il y a plus d'un
million de jeunes qui sont ni en emploi
ni à l'école 1900000 français qui qui
sont au RSA et 3 millions qui sont au
chômage qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et j'ajoute et
je termine rapidement sur cet article 3
Le travail l'activité professionnelle
n'est absolument pas une condition qui
permet d'éviter une radicalisation je
voudrais citer l'attentat symboliquement
de celui qui avait été perpétré à
rambouiller Jamel gorchen il était en
situation de travail il était chauffeur
livreur ce que nous voulons nous c'est
que le pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet
contrôle bien sûr l'activité réelle
professionnelle mais que on contrôle
dans ce
pouvoir discrétionnaire aussi la
capacité des individus à intégrer nos
propres valeurs c'est ce qui est
fondamental et c'est ce qui nous
distingue de ce fameux article 3 il y a
aussi le tabou je le disais du droit
parce que nous avons depuis des années
et des années abandonné les instruments
juridiques qui nous permettent de
réguler l'immigration et tout ça
débouche sur une impuissance
extraordinaire une impuissance coupable
que les Français constatent à chaque
fait divers qui nen sont plus des fait
divers bien évidemment cette impuissance
éta organisé d'abord par le législateur
qui a multiplié les protections les
exception à la règle et les exceptions
ont tué la règle et la règle peut tuer
des Français on l'a vu àas bien sûr si
cet individu caucasien avait été expulsé
le professeur Dominique Bernard serait
toujours en vie bien évidemment et
qu'importe s'il s'il est arrivé en
France avant son âge avant l'âge de de
13 ans nous ce que nous voulons ça n'est
pas multiplier les exceptions aux
exceptions ce que vous nous proposez ce
que nous voulons nous c'est anéantir les
exceptions pour que il y ait la règle
vis-à-vis des expulsions et vis-à-vis
des eqtf et que enfin on puisse aussi
rétablir ce que Hollande avait défait
c'est-à-dire le délu pour sé jours
irrégulier pour bien marqu que un pays
une nation une communauté nationale un
corps politique c'est un dedans et un
dehors tout simplement pour ce qui
concerne cette impuissance je voudrais
revenir un instant sur un certain nombre
de jurisprudenceces qui sont choquantes
surtout lorsqu'elles font
systématiquement en tout cas parfois
prévaloir les droits individuels la
protection des droits individuels sur
l'intérêt général sur un cadre collectif
sur le besoin d'un peuple de se protéger
je pourrais prendre plein d'exemples je
vais prendre des exemples que vous
connaissez bien bien la condamnation par
la CEDH de la France à la suite de
l'expulsion de deux tetchen radicalisé
comme vous le savez et dangereux euh et
là nous sommes condamnés parce que
l'expulsion de ces individus encore une
fois dangereux ne permettait pas d'avoir
une garantie suffisante qu'ils éent dans
leur propre pays d'origine un procès
équitable mais qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
faire protéger les Français ou protéger
ces individus dangereux vous avez
répondu d'ailleurs vous avez dit moi
préfère payer l'amende et vous avez bien
fait monsieur le ministre vous voyez ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que il
faut trouver monsieur le rapporteur un
juste équilibre entre l'État de droit
qui respecte les textes qui n'interprète
pas dans des interprétations très
créatives les traités et la démocratie
la souveraineté populaire retourner les
droits individuels systématiquement
contre la souveraineté populaire ça
n'est pas l'état de droit ça n'est plus
l'état de droit évidemment c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous voulons ce
référendum une révision de la
Constitution pour rendre aux Français
cette capacité à décider par eux-même la
politique migratoire Françis française
président de la République a fait un pas
il y a loin de la coupe aux lèvres on
n'est pas des perdau de l'année le
président du Sénat n'est plus là en tout
cas moi je ne suis plus un perd de
l'année et et nous attendrons de voir ce
qu'il advient de cette révision
constitutionnelle le le tabou politique
un un mot simplement sur le le en même
temps je disais que c'était un double
jeu parce que il y a un non dit dans
dans ce texte c'est le contexte de son
élaboration il il a fallu que vous soyez
écartelé entre une aile droite et une
aile gauche le problème c'est que en
même temps en matière migratoire ça ne
marche pas parce que les signaux que
vous allez envoyer au monde entier et
que vont très bien percevoir les
filières ce doit être un signal de
grande fermeté tout l'axisme sera
interprété comme un appel d'air et vous
savez que en France nous avons des
appels d'air on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir en matière en matière de
regroupement familial et cetera euh un
ouvrage un ouvrage un ouvrage été rédigé
par quelqu'un qui connaît très bien ces
chosesl et qui s'appelle Didier leski et
qui ne vient pas d'ailleurs de d'une
sucursale de la droite pour terminer
pour conclure monsieur le ministre pour
terminer pour terminer et conclure je
crois
que je pense que leur est grave parce
que on voit bien que jamais les risques
les
menaces de partition que les
menaces de fragmentation communautaire
non'ont autant fragilisé l'unité
française et nous en sommes parfaitement
conscients c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous abandonnerons ni aux postures
de ceux qui pourraient se contenter du
yakafucon
ou alors d'expédient de slogan mais on
se contentera pas non plus de
l'imposture de ceux qui qui appellent
l'ambigué qui appellent demi-mesure qui
appelle finalement le en même temps nous
voulons un texte efficace et nous
voulons un texte utile on verra on
commence l'examen de ce texte ou bien ce
texte donne les conditions et nous
feront des propositions des nombreuses
proposition d'amendement ou bien ces
propositions sont reprises ou bien on
durcit le texte ou bien on a la
conviction intime d'aller dans le sens
supérieur de la nation parce que les
français demandent cette fermeté et les
Français d'abord encore une fois d'en
bas pas les Français d'en haut bien et
alors nous pourrons voter le texte si en
revanche si en revanche nous sommes
persuadés qu'il y a une ambiguité qui
subsiste nous ne tricherons pas nous ne
jouerons pas les faux semblants et nous
nous opposerons à ce texte voilà notre
position elle est claire elle est très
très simple elle consiste à dire la
vérité au français et je pense que cet
enjeu il est énorme il est finalement si
je devais réduire en quelques mots de
faire en sorte que demain la République
soit partout chez elle en France merci
de votre
attention merci monsieur le président
retaillo la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur George patient pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
[Applaudissements]
indépendants monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'immigration dans les
oututromè aussi est une problématique de
première la réalité des outres mers en
matière d'immigration c'est d'être
humble face à l'immensité géographique
c'est pour la Guyane une frontière
fluviale sur 500 km dans la forêt
amazonienne avec le Surinam dans le PIB
par habitant est 10 fois inférieur à
celui de la
France avec le Brésil dans la frontière
est de 700
km la réalité des
outrers c'est pour les Antilles d'avoir
pour toute frontière la mer des Caraïbes
où le tourisme de Max jte la grande
délincance et la misère d'État insulaire
en déliquessence c'est également une
étendue maritime de 102 km dans l'océan
Indien qui ancre Mayotte à son destin
français les ordres de grandeur donc
dans les outrers sont loin d'être les
mêmes que dans
l'Hexagone il faut le savoir les deux
territoires Fran
les plus impactés par l'immigration sont
Mayot et la Guyane
ù plus de la moitié de la population
pour l'un et plus du tiers pour l'autre
est
étrangère aussi comme pour beaucoup de
mes collègues il me semble indispensable
d'avoir un débat au Parlement sur toutes
les adaptations qui devraient être
apporté en matière de gestion de
l'immigration dans les outrers c'est le
sens d'un des amendements que j'ai
déposé et qui a également été déposé sur
d'autres bancs et qui vise à supprimer
l'habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnance pour le gouvernement
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre j'ai le
sentiment que le gouvernement n'est pas
complètement opposé à la démarche
puisque certains amendements spécifiques
aux outromè déposés par mes collègues de
maotte ou moi-même avec ma collègue de
Guyane ont été travaillés avec votre
cabinet je pense notamment à
l'amendement qui permettra de répondre
au défis que représente la filière
d'immigration qui utilise les visas
humanitaires accordés par le BR pour
rentrer en Guyane avec l'Hexagone pour
destination finale en attendant son
adoption Cayenne et sa mère doivent
faire face à un afflux de migrants qui
en raison d'un manque de place
d'hébergement occupe l'espace public et
cristallise les
mécontentement pour autant le texte que
le gouvernement a déposé au Sénat début
février était relativement équilibré
apportant des réponses pragmatiques et
courageuses notamment pour tout ce qui
touche au travail des étrangers
ainsi les articles 3 et 4 sont
essentiels car ils améliorent l'accès au
travail des migrants ou des réfugiés or
le travail est le premier facteur
d'intégration de plus il faut cesser de
faire croire aux Français que nous
pourrions nous passer des
immigrés la DARES révélait dans une
étude de juillet 2021 que 22 % des
emplois en Île-de-France étaient
occupés par des
immigrés les métiers dans lesquels ils
sont sur représentés sont ceux où les
conditions de travail sont les plus
pénibles et les difficultés de
recrutement sont les plus fortes ainsi
jusqu'à présent toute un pan de notre
économie tourne grâce à une foule de
travailleurs sans papier qui viennent
palier le déficit de main-dœuvre ce
projet de loi va permettre ENF à ces
personnes et à leurs employeurs de
rentrer dans la légalité et toute la
société bénéficiera de retomber
positive ce projet de loi comporte
également notamment d'autres mesures qui
auront un impact positif important dans
les autres maires comme à l'article 7
avec la création d'une nouvelle carte de
séjour pour les médecins venant de pays
hors Union Européenne cette nouvelle
carte de séjour devrait permettre
d'améliorer le recrutement des pus qui
sont indispensables à nos établissements
de santé malheureusement la commission
des lois a supprimé une partie de la
mesure j'espère que les débats
permettront de revenir à la version
d'origine dans le même ordre d'idée j'ai
déposé en j'ai déposé un amendement pour
autoriser le recrutement d'infirmière en
Guyane or Union européenne comme cela se
fait déjà à Saint-Pierre et miclon vous
l'auriez compris qu'il y a des
évolutions positives et même
indispensable de dans ce texte cependant
l'actualité récente a tendu les esprits
et Durc les positions mais j'espère que
nous arriverons à avoir un débat serein
sur ces questions et que le bon sens
l'emportera la nécessité d'adapter en
permanence la loi aux évolutions de
l'immigration justifie ce projet de loi
la posture et l'affichage de fermeté de
certains ne doivent pas nous empêcher
d'apporter une réponse plus humède et
plus efficace je vous
remercie merci Monsieur passion la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
michaell Valy pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président madamees
et monsieurs les rapporteur Madame et
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues il
me revient de compléter la position du
groupe socialiste sur les aspects de
politique linguistique ainsi que sur les
éléments relatifs à la politique de
délivrance des visas du texte issu de la
commission s'agissant des dispositions
relatives à l'exigence d'un niveau de
français tout en louant l'objectif
théorique nous ne pouvons que regretter
les conclusions qu'en a tiré notamment
la commission je m'explique d'autres
pays dans le monde ont ce type
d'exigence bien légitime citons le
Québec son gouvernement actuel a
récemment relevé le niveau de français
exigé en même temps qu'il a augmenté le
nombre d'immigrés à accueillir qui peut
les blamé car dans leur cas il n'existe
qu'une alternative malheureuse au nouvel
arrivants qui ne parlent pas déjà
français devenir anglophone ce qui est
très malheureux et mettre à mal la
cohésion
nationale en France et espérons-le pour
encore longtemps il n'y a qu'une langue
commune et aucune autre capable de
s'imposer à elle la question du niveau
de français des immigrés pose donc moins
celle de la vivacité de notre langue
face à celle de chacun d'eux que celle
de leur propre capacité à travailler
vivre avoir des interactions sociale et
suivre la scolarité de leurs enfants
c'est en plus de l'intégration à la
québécoise en français l'idée de
l'intégration par le français ce n'est
donc pas la langue qui est menacée mais
la facilité pour les immigrés à
l'utiliser à des fins d'intégration
indispensable or ce qui nous est
présenté dans ce texte c'est-à-dire
exiger demain pour un titre de séjour
annuel ce que nous exigons aujourd'hui
pour un titre de séjour pluriannuel ne
semble pas poursuivre cet objectif
confondant le but par les Français et
l'outil le français considéré alors
comme un critère de tri préalable entre
étrangers car cet outil qui est la
langue à la manière d'un outil primaire
se forge se poit et voit affuter le
tranchant de Sal lame avec le temps il
faut donc donner le temps et les moyens
d'y parvenir que voulons-nous pour les
nouveaux immigrés et notamment les
travailleuses vous en avez parlé
monsieur le ministre un examen de
bachotage au bout d'un an ou une vraie
maîtrise de la langue sur le temps long
relever le niveau de langue exigé sans
s'en donner les moyens très concret ne
mène nulle part et c'est ce que nous
défendrons dans nos différents
amendements mon deuxième point porte sur
la disposition introduite en commission
consistant à offrir un nouveau motif
légal de refus de visa de long séjour
notamment aux ressortissant d'un État
délivrant un nombre particulièrement
faible de laisser passer
consulaire nous le disons clairement il
n'est pas tenable que des états sabotent
la mise en œuvre de décision de justice
française en organisant de manière
systémique leur incapacité supposée à
reconnaître tre leurs nationaux mais
nous socialistes considérant considérons
que l'introduction dans la loi de cette
politique de rétorsion ne permettra pas
d'atteindre l'objectif annoncé encore
une fois que nous partageons en grande
partie je le redis il arrive que la
diplomatie réclame un peu de finesse et
que cette finesse échappe à la pensée la
plus complexe de nos plus hauts
dirigeants déjà en froid avec nos
voisins méditerranéens et avec les
opinions africaines nous enverrions un
signal public bien dommageable si les
États n'ont pas seulement des valeurs
mais aussi des intérêts à commencer par
Le Nôtre le travail des chancelleries
vaut parfois mieux pour les faire
respecter qu'une démonstration de
virilité législative
contre-productive le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs expérimenté cette méthode à
compté du printemps 2021 avec les pays
du Maghreb pour constater l'échec et y
renoncer dès 2022 et oui la diplomatie
comme la préfectorale d'ailleurs c'est
un métier enfin traitant des aspects
internationaux de ce projet de loi je me
dois d'évoquer notre maire commune la
Méditerranée et ce cimetière qu'elle est
devenu la Méditerranée berceau de
civilisation au pluriel et matrice de
tant de cultures dont la nôtre française
on y meurt par centaine dans une
indifférence dramatique formulons le
souhait que notre pays sache malgré les
vents mauvais qui nous agite et agite
l'opinion continuer à distinguer d'une
part les nécessaires débats sur les
politiques migratoires que nous allons
avoir présentement et d'autre part la
nécessité absolue de sauver des vies
quel que soit le contexte et sans aucune
condition préalable à ce propos
justement sur la Méditerranée depuis le
début des débats monsieur le ministre
vous avez cité le président Hollande la
majorité sénatoriale nous l'avons
entendu tout à l'heure a eu l'occasion
de citer le président mitteran mais il
est grand le mystère de la droite il n'y
a personne pour évoquer les déclarations
réchantes du chef d'État vaticané
peut-être aurons-nous l'occasion de le
faire pendant les débats en tout cas
c'est désormais chose faite dans les
discours d'introduction
décidément les socialistes doivent tout
faire ici je vous
remercie merci merci beaucoup monsieur
valet maintenant la parole est au
Président Monsieur François Noël buffet
pour le groupe les républicains pour 7
minutes monsieur le ministre madame et
monsieurs le les rapporteurs pardon
monsieur le Président chers collègues
quelques mots tout d'abord un point de
constat et ensuite peut-être une
explication sur la stratégie que nous
souhaitons développer après la crise du
covid-19 notre pays a renoué d'abord
avec des flux migratoires irréguliers
très important selon d'ailleurs les
chiffres de Frontex
230350 personnes ont franchi
irrégulièrement les frontières de
l'Union européenne sur les 8 premiers
mois de l'année 2023 soit le niveau le
plus haut de depuis 2016 puis de 80 près
de 90000 personnes ont fait l'objet d'un
refus d'entrée à nos frontières en 2022
là aussi un record sur notre sol le
nombre de personnes en situation
irrégulière ne cesse de grandir le
nombre de bénéficiaires d'ailleurs de
l'Ame qui est un critère parmi d'autres
mais qui ne suffit pas naturellement
nous annonce 400000 personnes en 2022
soit 100000 de plus qu'il y a 10 ans
pourrait naturellement continuer pendant
longtemps d'égrainer ce type de chiffre
c'est UNCAC cé à maîtriser nos
frontières est d'autant plus inquiétante
que évidemment elle pose le problème de
la reconduite dans les pays d'origine
dont nous savons que malgré les 120000
octf qui ont été prononcés ces dernières
années à peu près 10000 ont été exécuté
ce qui reste mais l'indicateur est
imparfait parce qu'il faut tenir compte
effectivement de la difficulté à obtenir
des laissés passer consulaires même
d'ailleurs notre politique d'immigration
régulière cette fois-ci nous n'avons
jamais délivré autant de titre de séjour
316000 premiers titres en 2022 et pour
autant nous intégrons de moins en moins
bien je dis bien de moins en moins bien
je rappelle que d'ailleurs la plupart
des étrangers qui arrivent sur le
territoire parlent ou écrivent mal le
français à l'essue de leur première
année de séjour et je ne parle pas non
plus des crises des rendez-vous que dans
les préfectures tout cela finalement
montre les difficultés la situation
n'est pas si différente s'agissant de la
politique de l'asile l'pra comme la CNDA
sont au bord de l'embolie nous le savons
en 2023 il y aura pratiquement 140000
demandes et les prévision du
gouvernement sont de l'ordre de 160000
pour
2024 évidemment la dét la détérioration
des délais va venir complexifier les
choses alors face à cette situation le
texte arrive très bien quel est le
critère de départ que nous devons
semble-t-il déterminer quelle politique
migratoire de quel politique migratoire
la France veut-elle se doter et une fois
qu'elle aura fait le choix encore
faut-il que les mesures qui soient
prises soient très clair et
compréhensible par tout le monde il me
semble que nous avons besoin d'abord de
définir ceci et cette clarté me paraît
se traduire à travers trois points très
simples le premier c'est que
l'immigration régulière doit être une
immigration choisie que cette
immigration choisie doit correspondre à
naturellement une baisse de
l'immigration régulière actuellement est
choisi sur la base plutôt d'une d'une
immigration économique qualifiée
j'entendais tout à l'heure que on nous
disait que potentiellement l'immigration
était une chance sans doute à quelle
condition il suffit de relire le rapport
de l'OCDE de 2021 qui dit très
clairement que en France notre
difficulté c'est que notre immigration
sur le plan économique n'est pas
qualifiée et que c'est notre handicap
c'est pas nous qui le disons c'est l'OCD
qui le dit et donc nous avons besoin de
nous recentrer sur une immigration
économique qualifiée en nombre
moins important qu'aujourd'hui par même
beaucoup moins important de façon à
faciliter évidemment l'intégration le
deuxème point quel est-il ben c'est
l'intransigence dans la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière nous ne
pouvons pas continuer comme cela par le
nombre de procédures possibles pour
détourner les objectifs qui sont fixés
par différents différentes procédures
qui veulent éloigner les étrangers c'est
la première chose des procédures très
complexes il y a pratiquement 13 ou 14
moyens de saisir les tribunaux
administratifs le rapport que nous avons
rendu au Sénat il y a quelques années
enfin il y a un peu plus d'un an
démontre à l'évidence que les
juridictions administratives sont
absolument en situation de saturation le
nier serait tout de même inacceptable il
faut donc simplifier c'est l'objectif du
texte l'objectif du rapport qui a été en
partie repris dans le texte et c'est
important que de le dire mais c'est
aussi la capacité de pouvoir répondre
rapidement aux demandes des uns et des
autres et aussi situation des uns et des
autres et puis c'est la capacité
d'établir disons-le ici le rapport de
force avec les pays d'origine parce
qu'il faudra bien de toute façon
continuer d'obtenir des laisser passer
consulair et que cela ne peut ne peut se
faire monsieur le ministre je crois que
vous le savez j'imagine que tout le
monde le sait que si notre position sur
notre stratégie est parfaitement claire
pour qu'elle soit parfaitement comprise
et que l'on se donne les moyens de ce
rapport de force fustil difficile il
faut néanmoins le porter sinon il n'y a
pas de choix et puis enfin il y a la
question les les problématiques des
procédures d'asile nous savons tous ici
que la procédure d'asile telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui voir depuis plusieurs
années qu'elle sert de détournement à
l'objectif qui est le sien la majorité
des demandes sont la très grande
majorité des demandes sont faites
uniquement pour permettre de rester sur
le territoire national en espérant
rester le plus longtemps possible et
bénéficier éventuellement d'autres
moyens de protection qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien celui qui mérite d'être
protégé d'avoir le statut de réfugié
attend des années et des années et et
les autres attendent tranquillement la
décision en se disant que plus elle sera
tardive mieux ce sera et qu' en tiront
un profit nous sommes victimes deux fois
ceux qui méritent la protection rapide
de la France et on a raison de la donner
et ils étaient à peu près 35000 se
feront de ma part ces dernières années
et il faudrait aller vite mais ceux qui
ne la méritent pas doivent le savoir
également rapidement pour qu'il puissent
être reconduit dans leur pays d'origine
bien sûr c'est donc à la faveur de ces
trois constats et à mon avis de ces
trois stratégies qu'on pourra
potentiellement avancer sérieusement et
doter not notre pays de politique
migratoire faut-il pour autant dire que
nous sommes très durs oui nous sommes
fermes bien sûr nous sommes fermes nous
voulons être fermes car le message que
nous enverrons est tout aussi important
que ce qu'il y aura dans le texte mais
nous devons aussi être responsable
c'est-à-dire se doter de moyens
suffisants pour pouvoir intégrer ce que
l'on accepte sur notre territoire et
nous avons fixé des un certain nombre de
règles d'ailleurs à la commission des
lois les rapporteurs l'ont dit très
clairement alors puisque mon temps est
compté si je puis dire il reste 30
secondes je voudrais simplement insister
sur le fait que ce texte en tous les cas
pour nous dans notre groupe et je crois
pour la majorité consiste à mettre de la
clarté pour obtenir de l'efficacité à la
fois pour ceux que l'on accueille et les
accueillir de façon qualitative et enfin
de la fermeté de l'efficacité à l'égard
de ceux qu'on ne veut pas voir sur le
territoire qui doivent repartir la
question étant que tout cela se passe
dans des procédures certes respectueuses
mais extrêmement rapides c'est tout
l'objet de ce que nous avons fait à la
commission des lois et que probablement
les débats qui sont les nôtres
permettront d'aborder dans les jours qui
viennent pour ne pas dire dans les
heures qui viennent voilà je vous
remercie de votre
attention merci président buffet la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Roger
caroci pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Madame et
Monsieur le
Rapporteur certes un enè texte sur
l'immigration
quelleimportance notre premier texte en
la matière sur la nationalité les
étrangers l'immigration date de
1889 et depuis tous les gouvernements de
gauche et de droite du Centre ou
d'ailleurs ont tous fait des textes
pendant le Front populaire avant la
guerre de 14 avant dans les années 50 et
encore aujourd'hui tous avec les mêmes
fondements
l'immigration est une politique
régalienne
elle doit être déterminée par un
gouvernement et par un état sur ce que
représente sa capacité à intégrer ce que
représente sa capacité à maintenir
l'unité de sa nation
sa capacité à laisser la société dans
l'état dans lequel elle
est aujourd'hui c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre un nouveau texte bon après
celui de 2018 mais la situation a bien
changé sur les 15 20 dernières années je
représente j'ai cette chance et cet
honneur le Sénat à l'office français
d'immigration et
d'intégration et à plusieurs reprises je
me suis exprimé à la Commission des fin
comme dans cet hémicycle pour réussir
l'intégration je le dis manière très
calme mais très
sûre nous n'y parvenons plus nous n'y
parvenons plus parce qu'un pays qui a
plus de 3000 milliards d'euros de dett
parce qu'un pays qui a les déficits
budgétaires qui sont les siens
aujourd'hui parce qu'un pays qui a les
fractures sociales et sociétales qui
sont les nôtres aujourd'hui et dans la
difficulté à la fois matérielle
financière pour intégrer mais il est
aussi dans la difficulté de la
transmission les pays qui peuvent et qui
ont fait par exemple lorsque Angela
Merkel a accepté un nombre de migrants
importants sur une seule année c'était
une époque où l'Allemagne était dans une
situation forte financièrement
économiquement humainement si
aujourd'hui Olaf Scholz change de
politique c'est parce que l'Allemagne
n'est plus dans cette situation si
aujourd'hui la France doit remettre en
cause les mouvements migratoires tels
qu'ils sont c'est parce que le pays
n'est plus dans la situation d'il y a 30
ans d' y a 40 ans oui bien sûr la France
c'est son honneur avant la guerre de 14
elle a intégré très bien les Italiens
les Polonais qui venaient dans l'entre
de guerre des Italiens des Espagnols
après la deuxème guerre mondiale des
Portugais des al algérien qui est arrivé
et l'intégration s'est bien passé il
faut le dire très clairement jusque dans
les années 670 l'intégration a été une
force de la France elle ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui parce que la société
française a changé parce que
malheureusement c'est la vie l'économie
française n'est plus ce qu'elle été
parce que nous n'avons plus la capacité
d'intégrer des grands nombres je ne sais
plus qu' l' a dit tout à l'heure oui
l'intégration est facile si vous avez un
petit nombre parce qu'alors les
structures de l'État les structures des
collectivités locales que je reconnais
prennent en main réussissent cette
intégration lorsque le nombre est trop
important et bien cela ne fonctionne
plus j'ai été de ceux qui ici dans cette
hémicycle on demandait à ce qu'à l'issue
des cours de français il y ait un examen
parce que membre de l'OFI j'allais
régulièrement dans les salles je n'en
parle pas comme ça dans les salles pour
voir que bien des gens venaient parfois
malheureusement les hommes imposés aux
femmes qui étaient là de se voiler de ne
pas prendre la parole pendant les cours
et à la fin on disait bah ils ont été
présents 80h ils ont été présentensem
20h il y a donc pas à vérifier qu'il
sacheent le moindre mot de français ça
n'est pas acceptable nous sommes en
République nous défendons la République
la République elle est là pour tous mais
elle est là aussi pour faire en sorte
que la société française ne soit pas
davantage fr tuis elle est suffisamment
comme ça nous avons en tant qu'élu tous
ici une responsabilité première faire en
sorte que la France reste la nation
unique elle a toujours été par le passé
par rapport à ses opposants par rapport
à la compétition internationale si nous
ne sommes pas capables d'assurer cela
comment voulez-vous que nous soyons
capables d'intégrer d'autres de faire en
sorte que les valeurs française
républicaine et nationale soi transmis à
d'autres alors que nous ne sommes même
pas capables aujourd'hui de faire en
sorte qu'elle soit totalement assimilée
par la société française nous avons donc
une introspection tous à faire à gauche
à droite au centre tout le monde est
responsable de la situation actuelle
nous n'avons pas vu la société française
se fracturer de plus en plus nous
n'avons pas vu notre quasi impossibilité
d'intégrer d'où aujourd'hui ces
territoires perdus ces quartiers
difficile parce que en réalité à un
moment donné l'inversion ne s'est pas
faite dans nos politiques et nous avons
cru peut-être sûrement avec trop
d'angélisme que nous y parviendrions
puisque nos ancêtres y étaient parvenu
dans les années 1900 dans les années
1950 nous ne sommes plus ni la France ni
l'Europe ni le monde des années 50 nous
n'y parvenons plus et nous avons
absolument besoin maintenant d'avoir une
immigration choisie d'avoir une maîtrise
des flux de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
beaucoup moins d'entrée sur le
territoire national pour pouvoir ir
intégrer ceux qui veulent réellement
devenir Français participer à l'économie
française participer à la société
française être fiers d'être français au
terme de leur intégration nous ne
pouvons plus faire en sorte que nous
ayons des apports tellement massifs
qu'ils ne sont pas intégrés pas
assimilés et qu'en réalité nous
fabriquons nous-mêmes des anti-France de
l'avenir la responsabilité de la France
la responsabilité des élus c'est de dire
voilà les moyens dont nous disposons
voilà ce que nous pouvons accepter voilà
ce que nous ne pouvons pas accepter
n'allons pas au-delà parce que si nous
allons au-delà et bien en réalité nous
ne faisons pas de la bonne politique
migratoire nous ne faisons pas de la
bonne politique d'asile on l'a dit tout
à l'heure aujourd'hui 140000 demandes
d'asile c'est un détournement manifeste
il y a 10 ans 15 ans il y en avait 35000
donc clairement on demande l'asile pour
faire un détournement de l'immigration
économique nous avons des structures
qu'il faut reprendre en main parce que
si nous voulons avoir des immigrés qui
demain soient fier d'être français il
faut qu'ils soi parfaitement intégrés et
pour être parfaitement intégrés ils
doivent être moins nombreux ceux qui
rentrent sur le territoire de manière
illégale doivent être reconduits à la
frontière et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que notre système explose en
vol merci merci Monsieur
kucci maintenant la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur géralde
armanin merci Monsieur le le Président
je vrais évidemment remercier tous les
orateurs qui se sont exprimés en
commencer par remercier ceux qui
apportent un soutien d'ors et déjà au
texte du Gouvernement bien sûr le groupe
RDPI le groupe centriste groupe des
indépendants j'ai compris qu'il y avait
des on va voir on va voir du groupe du
RDSE on va voir du groupe les
républicains et puis j'ai compris qu'il
y avait par nature des gens qui
souhaitent s'opposer au gouvernement
même si ne refuse pas la
discussion par définition ou par
introduction sans sans faire le débat
sans faire le débat d'avance mais ouvert
à à certain nombre de propositions c'est
le GR du tout cas du groupe communiste
pour faire vide du groupe socialiste et
et du groupe écologiste je pas répondre
à tous les orateurs mais peut-être à
quelques-uns d'entre vous soit parce que
les propos me semblent apporter si il le
permettent un complément de la part du
du gouvernement soit répondre à un
certain nombre de questions soit pour
préciser un certain nombre de de termes
puisqu'on va passer quelques jours et
peut-être quelques nuits à travailler
sur ce texte
important bien évidemment monsieur euh
[Musique]
benarche je je je pense qu'il faut que
dès le début on essaye tous ensemble me
semble-t-il de nous poser les les
questions qui correspondent non pas à
des présupposés ou des postures mais
bien des réalités vous dites par exemple
vous voulez l'intégration et puis vous
baissez les crédits de Lada mais c'est
en fait assez cohérent avec le texte du
gouvernement puisque si j'avais inscrit
dans le budget de l'année prochaine une
l' augmentation des crédits de Lada qui
est donc le versement de l'aide sociale
que nous donnons au demandeurs d'asile
ça veut dire que j'anticipe le fait que
le texte sera pas efficace puisque le
principe de ce texte c'est de pouvoir
simplifier les procédures pour très vite
comme l'a dit le président de la
commission des loi et comme j'essayé de
vous le démontrer dire oui ou dire non à
quelqu'un et l'inscription àada elle est
automatique ça arrivera à tous les
ministres de l'Intérieur qui me
succéderont il ne discute pas du montant
de Lada dans le budget avec les
parlementaires le Conseil d'État consid
dire qu'effectivement c'est le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile qui aura sur le
territoire national le temps qu'ils sont
en demande d'asile si j'avais présenté
au Parlement une augmentation de la D
vous m'iez dit sans doute au côté droit
de l'hémicycle cher amis c'est bien
sympathique vous prévoyez déjà que votre
texte de loi le 20e le 25e le 30e n'est
pas efficace j'essaaye d'être d'être
cohérent monsieur monsieur benarach ce
qui ne veut pas dire vous l'avez pas dit
complètement qu'on n pas augmenté tous
les autres crédits d'intégration dans le
budget que je vous ai présenté pour
l'année prochaine puisque tous les
autres crédits d'intégration y compris
ceux qui concerne l'intégration par la
langue augmente donc oui la D baisse la
D baisse parce que nous réussirons j'en
suis certain à aller plus vite dans les
procédure de demande d'asile grâce à
cette loi et grâce au travail essentiel
que font les agents de l'OFPRA mais non
les crédits d'intégration ne baissent
pas ils augmente notamment par la langue
je vrais d'ailleurs dire ici à Monsieur
caouci et peut-être à Monsieur rotillo
que Monsieur schols en effet prend des
mesures de restriction désormais de
l'immigration mais un peu tard je vous
rappelle que si nous nous sommes entre
130000 et 140000 demandes d'asile au
moment où je vous parle qui à peu près
le chiffre de l'année dernière en légère
augmentation c'est vrai l'Allemagne est
à 230000 au moment où nous parlons quand
je suis devenu ministre de l'Intérieur
nous étions à 120000 demandes d'asile
quand l'Allemagne était à 160000 3 ans
après nous sommes à 130000 140000 on
verra la fin de l'année l'Allemagne est
à 225000 il referme après avoir beaucoup
ouvert et et je pense qu'il faut aussi
le dire ainsi sinon on ne comprend pas
la position qu' a désormais monsieur
schols en effet qui n'est pas dans la
même position que les socialistes
français manifestement monsieur benage
vous avez évoqué également la protection
temporaire que nous offrons aux
Ukrainiens ça a été également évoqué par
Monsieur Dosu vous dites finalement et
ça je l'entends assez facilement
pourquoi on ne fait pas comme avec les
Ukrainiens mais j'allais vous dire
chiche mais je suis pas sûr que c'est ce
que vous voulez défendre au fond c'est
quoi la protection temporaire que nous
avons décidé tous les ministres de
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne
ensemble pour les Ukrainiens c'est que
justement donz pas l'asile et qu'on leur
disait Mesdames et Messieurs les
Ukrainiens vous avez 3 ans dans 3 ans
vous n'avez plus la protection la
différence fondamental avec un Afghan
première demande d'asile française c'est
que nous donnons l'asile à vitam à etnam
on ne conditionne pas la fin de l'asile
au retour d' vie démocratique dans leur
pays nous nous pensons que nous allons
gagner la guerre contre la Russie en
aidant les Ukrainiens pendant un certain
temps bah oui nous les accueillons sur
le territoire européen tous les
Européens ensemble en échange de quoi
bien sûr ils peuvent travailler dès le
premier jour mais je vous signale
monsieur benarche queils n'ont pas
l'asile et certains se sont élevés à
l'époque des associations pour dire
pourquoi vous donnez pas l'asile aux
Ukrainiens mais parce que nous pensons
que nous vons pouvoir retourner très
rapidement dans leur pays si la solution
que vous proposez au groupe écologiste
c'est de dire on arrête la demande
d'asile tel qu'elle existe depuis la
Révolution française ou la Convention de
Genève et on la remplace par la
protection temporaire qu'on offre aux
Ukrainiens c'est pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui troua à redire sauf à
considérer que vous êtes beaucoup trop
dur avec les demandeurs d'asile
peut-être pour revenir aussi à la
question de Monsieur brossa dont j'ai
goûté et j'ai été sensible à quelquesuns
de ces arguments sans être d'accord
évidemment sur le sur le fond de son
intervention en général je peux
comprendre
votre distinction pays d'accueil pays
d'arrivée pour savoir qu'est-ce qui
motive le départ finalement de ces
personnes je pense que il y a des
raisons extrêmement diverses si on est
tout à fait entre nous il y a des pays
il y a des grands pays d'Afrique qui
offrent une couverture sociale
extrêmement forte à leur personnes à
leur cito oyen le le logement gratuit le
gaz quasi gratuit l'essence quasi
gratuit les produits de premiè nécessité
quasi gratuit le chômage et il est si on
compare les choses assez vrai qu'il ne
trouve pas en France la même protection
en tout cas une protection beaucoup plus
différente que ce qu'ils ont et ce
départ et parfois le départ de cette
jeunesse mais aussi de catégories social
professionnelle plus élevé c'est aussi
un mode de vie qui vient chercher en
France donc c'est vrai qu'il ne viennent
pas chercher que des question
de protection sociale ça peut être le
cas c'est pas tout à fait vrai mais ça
peut être le cas ils peuvent chercher un
mode de vie et ils peuvent chercher une
protection protection dans l'orientation
sexuelle protection religieuse
protection politique bien évidemment je
pense qu'il y a diverses interprétation
je crois que ce serait faux de dire que
les personnes qui viennent en France ou
en Europe ne cherchent que le modèle
social français même si' il est
effectivement généreux et qui n'est pas
aussi vrai vous l'avez dit vousmême pour
le RSA en faisant une distinction exprès
j'imagine à la tribune que ce qu'on dit
c'est vrai que les personnes
irrégulières ne touchent pas le RSA en
France on l'entend beaucoup mais ce
n'est pas vrai bon alors cependant il y
a quand même une mesure
d'attractivité qu'on ne peut pas nier
monsieur brossa et l'honnêteté
intellectuelle nous pousse à à l' voir
quand 40 % des demandeurs d'asile dans
les 100 % demandeurs d'asile que la
France a viennent d'autres pays
européens c'est qu'il y a quand même une
comparaison
d'attractivité sinon on quitterait son
pays en guerre son pays dans lequel on a
un certain nombre de persécutions
religieuses politiques quand on arrive
en Italie quand on arrive même en Suisse
ce qui est dans l'espace Schengen quand
on arrive en Belgique quand on arrive en
Espagne on devrait pas avoir envie
d'aller dans un autre pays de l'espace
européen puisque on y trouve là une
démocratie un accompagnement politique
évidemment puisque nous avons signé à
peu près les mêmes traités qui
garantissent les droits de l'homme la
vérité de sa propre existence
personnelle quand 40 % des demandeurs
d'asile que nous avons àof pra onou en
fait déposer l'asile dans un autre pays
européen c'est bien quelque chose qui ne
va pas soit tous les demandeurs d'asile
sont devenus des personnes qui
multiplient demand d'asile partout en
Europe et vous savez bien que dans les
conditions dans lesquelles il livent ce
n'est pas vrai soit il trouvve en France
soit un intérêt linguistique il viennent
rejoindre une communauté qu'il
connaissent c'est possible soit il
revient d'une famille ce qui explique
qu'une partie d'entre eux vont en
Grande-Bretagne parce qu'ils trouvent
beaucoup de gens il y a plus d'un
million d'irréguliers en Grande-Bretagne
qui qui évidemment les poussent à
rejoindre leurs père leur mère leurs
fiancé ou leurs enfants soit ils y
trouvent des moyens de travailler sans
le dire en tout cas pas officiellement
et c'est pour ça que le texte vise à
lutter contre cet écosystème qui est en
effet irrégulier soit ils y trouve une
attractivité sociale et c'est pas un
mauvais mot je serai à leur place je
ferai exactement la même chose et dans
ce cas-là je pense que notre position
c'est d'avoir la même position que
l'ensemble des pays européens le jour où
nous avons une politique européenne de
d'attractivité sociale mais Ben très
bien il y aura plus de comparaison de
pays à pays donc je crois que ce que
vous dites est à la fois juste mais
permettez-moi de dire qu'il y a quand
même une partie de ces personnes qui qui
viennent en France pour des mesures sans
doute qui consistent à y trouver des
avantages qui n'ont pas dans notutes
pays encore une fois il y a aucun
jugement moral c'est un constat après
est-ce qu'on l'assume ou est-ce qu'on
l'assume pas c'est une une évidemment
une décision politique qui appartient à
des débats politiques ce que je dis moi
en revanche et je pense que c'est un
débat très important parce qu'il faut
qu'on essaie d'être honnête dans nos
convictions je ne suis pas tout à fait
certain que les gens viennent en France
par notre modèle social mais je suis peu
près certain qu'ils IR reste par notre
modèle social ce qui est assez différent
c'estàd que je pense qu'arriver en
France après un long voyage un long
voyage difficile je ne suis pas certain
qu'en effet il peut y avoir en effet des
filières de peurs qui promeuvent le
modèle français je je le je n'en
disconviens pas et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement corriger ça mais il est
certain en tout cas moi de ce que je
vois depuis 3 ans et demi que je suis
ministre d'intérieur c'est que des gens
restent parce que nous avons pas un
système assez désincitatif aux personnes
de repartir parce que quand vous êtes
quelqu'un qui est en arrêt en en uktf
confirmé par la justice c'est quelqu'un
qui a passé un certain temps sur le
territoire national il peut donc
travailler il peut créer sa boîte
d'autoentreprise sans qu'on il demande
des papiers à ber pour servir les repas
ou pour conduire des personnes dans des
voitures je vous rappelle que cette
disposition existe dans le texte de loi
jusqu'à présent vous pouvez créer votre
auto-entreprise sans qu'on vous demande
vos papiers voilà une voilà une une
machine à créer de larégularité c'est
quand même ce que fait la loi française
aujourd'hui voilà pourquoi cette loi est
nécessaire donc vous pouvez venir
irrégulier sur le territoire national on
vous a refusé tout votre demande de
titre de séjour Votre demande d'asil
vous pouvez quand même créer votre
entreprise ou d'ailleurs vous payez des
impôts des charges sociales sans
bénéficier des charges sociales enfin de
la protection sociale vous pouvez on l'a
vu accéder à un logement et notamment un
logement social vous pouvez accéder à la
santé et notamment dans le cadre de
laame vous avez même 100 % de la
couverture après 9 mois pour des raisons
qu'on pourra d'ailleurs évoquer dans le
débat et qui sont pas a priori moi je la
me je suis ni tothémique pour la
supprimer ni tothémique pour la garder
je pensece qu'il faut qu'on regarde les
choses calmement sereinement et et qu'on
essaie d'en discuter et qu'il faut
évidemment soigner toutes les personnes
qui se présentent devant le système
français enfin c'est un fait que vous
êtes plus couvert après 9 mois
d'irrégularité qu'avant 9 mois
d'irrégularité et vous pouvez dans des
conditions que nous avons évoqué vivre
sans partager les valeurs de la
République en aucune manière et sans
surtout parler français ça incite pas
les gens à partir directement de notre
pays sont puisque vous savez bien que
l'essentiel des TF sont des départs
volontaires l'essentiel des TF que nous
mettons c'est je remets un arrêté de
reconduite à la frontière à quelqu'un
qui doit l'exécuter lui-même c'est c'est
très petit le nombre de qtf qui sont des
départs forcés avec des policiers qui
les amènent à l'aéroport donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on qu'on tire des des des
conclusions du fait qu'on ait dit non et
définitivement non à une personne on
peut pas l'accompagner évidemment
socialement sinon il y a une sorte de
contradiction dans notre politique
publique et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
que nous voyons les demandeurs d'asile
et notamment l'accompagnement social
quel qu'il soit autour de ça je pense
que c'est très juste que de dire c'est
ce que font tous les pays autour de nous
euh je je voudrais dire peut-être à à
Madame Nara cigouin j'espère que je
prononce bien votre nom Nara cuin pardon
madame la la sénatrice vous avez utilisé
plusieurs fois le terme de de migrant ce
que d'autres interlocuteurs n'ont pas
forcément fait moi peut-être que nous
pourrions tous nommer les choses
correctement le terme de migrant général
est difficile moi je je je ne l'utilise
pas parce que soit vous avez des
demandeurs d'asile et dans ces CASL il
faut étudier leur demande d'asile et la
question savoir si on répond vite et on
dit OUI ou on dit non soit vous avez des
gens qui viennent par regoupement
familial ou réunification familiale ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
bon soit vous avez des travailleurs qui
viennent pour le pour le des immigrés
qui viennent pour les questions
économiques soit vous avez des
clandestins mais derrière le terme
migrant il y a toute sé
vérité effectivement quand on dit
migrant on a l'impression que c'est des
personnes qui quoi qu'il arrive sont
persécuté pour ce qu'ils font et on leur
doit l'accueil moi je pense que ce n'est
pas le cas quand vous avez des
Sénégalais des Ivoiriens des Marocains
qui viennent demander euh l'asile comme
migrant à Lampedusa je je me dis que non
ce n'est pas possible première demande
de migr première demande d'asile
l'Afghanistan ça peut tout à fait se
comprendre très gros taux de protection
deuxième demande d'asile en France
Bangladesh déjà un peu plus compliqué à
comprendre mais on peut comprendre les
réfugiés climatiques qui existent au
bangladesch j' essayie de m'intéresser à
cette question euh trè demande demande
d'asile c'est pas du tout un pays en
guerre c'est pas du tout un pays sur
lequel nous n'avons pas de relation
diplomatique c'est pas du tout un pays
où fait pas de de développement et quand
je vois des Sénégalais des Gabonais des
Ivoiriens des Marocains des Tunisiens
qui demandent l'asile en France hormis
des cas qui peuvent se comprendre
exceptionnels il y a quand même pas 80 %
de personnes qui sont persécuté dans ces
pays-là vous le savez bien c'est des
immigrés économiques et appelonsles
comme tels des immigrés économiques et
donc il faut pas qu'ils passe par
l'asile parce que il ils embolisent la
demande d'asile de ceux qui méritent
l'asile et la protection la plus rapide
du territoire de la République et elles
font la défiance elles font la défiance
pour les Français mais appelons les
parlant non ce sont soit des clandestins
soit des travailleurs économiques soit
des personnes qui sont des demandeurs
d'asile mais migrant me paraît un terme
qui consiste à cacher des vérités qui
sont très différentes selon les
étrangers euh pour Monsieur monsieur
rotillot vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de choses j' reviendrai pas on
aura sans doute de de long débats mais
peut-être la question du nombre que vous
évoqué et quand tout à l'heure les
rapporteurs notamment évoquent la